[Music]
two everybody the time has come it is
Wednesday December
13th the year
2023 the show sound bite tournament 2023
is my one of my favorite shows of the
year I always look forward to it and uh
boy we have a
stiff stiff competition this year in
fact we came we started early because we
know that these shows take time and we
do not like to rush the process uh we
need to take this methodically and
patiently but uh We've basically have a
monster list we've even crowdsourced to
the audience cuz I'll never forget I
don't know if it was the first or second
year we did this time when we forgot
peace and love I mean like what so I
don't ever want that to happen this is
the first time for me so do you guys
find any interesting ones from the crowd
sourcery yeah I mean there was lots the
thing is is like the year the year is so
long turns out it's like a year long
it's and oh yeah stuff that I thought
what happened forever ago it's like oh
no that was just in March of this year
and so sometimes we're just reminded
it's like oh yeah that was this year
yeah thank you Jordan um
um so I mean that's going to be the
whole show there's a couple things I
want to touch on real quick at the top
first of all thank you to stamps.com
thank
you cheers my dude also people are
buzzing ela's birthday was yesterday I
had a fun day planned I don't know if
you can you guys tell my nails are like
did you get a Manny I got a Manny P
panty they're stuning can you see them
yeah they're glistening from all I can't
my previewer is not up oh here I got to
top coat oh you can't really see them no
they look amazing no it looks gorgeous
look you look so pretty my toes you want
to see uh if you want to give that up
for free that's on you wow oh my God
they're so
pretty hold it up and I'll get a zoom
here yeah higher
higher looks like you're dropping put it
right in the water
there no yeah dude
woo I want to talk about
feet thank you that looks so cute dude
I'm going to need a new
water okay I trust my feet I don't think
they're that dirty but you know but
anyway so thank you
Olivia um so yeah we did we did um I
think I won the birthday Olympics did
you I think I did a perfect day really
yeah so first and her mom came with us
so that was a nice extra treat nice so
we went the Manny pany Manny Petty
uhhuh which I've never done like going
to the salon and doing the whole thing
the lady I can't say it was the best she
was very aggressive with like there's
this specific cutting tool they Ed to
cut the top part the skin here cuticle
cutter cuticle cutter I believe that's
what that is and she was very aggressive
I was was actually bleeding from one of
my cuticles you got to be really careful
that my dad has a really bad
infection on his finger from getting a
manicure really it's like staff
infection what yeah you should his
finger was blown the up it's like
oozing with pus oh no heard every time I
push my cuticle back I alcohol it a
little bit I never touched that part of
my body right never thought about it but
this lady was very aggressive she would
cut and Pull and the pull I didn't like
the pulling yeah
uhuh
but then the other thing was um
everything else was fine other than that
so after that we went to um the
spa oh nice we got uh massage and
facials nice amazing I got a facial and
the lady went to war on my sound
face don't sound B
that grow up
Dan and she went to war on my face dude
she was like Po in every pore
open I felt like my face got blow
torched like I was in pain the whole
time but I guess I don't know if that I
don't know if I believe in
facials if they work if it does anything
when I had like horrible horrible acne
and I would get facials I would leave
crying sometimes it's so painful painful
oh my God why are they like that I know
but you but you kept doing them did you
think that it helped you definitely like
especially when my face was clearing out
I just had so much like you just
had to get it out because I was
producing more so like the least amount
of zits possible is what I was trying to
achieve and like yeah I guess yeah it's
hard to know especially if you're like
going through puberty or whatever I did
ACU that Works everyone who I know
did that has like Perfect Skin yeah it
did work I'm nervous
that it's I'm going to have to go back
on it why cuz I've been getting like a
couple it's that's you're not supposed
to so if you do start getting zits like
it's possible that your acne could come
back so I have to keep an eye on it well
I think a couple zits here and there I'd
be more worried about like oily pores
that's the thing that me up that I
have had my whole life and the ladies
like you have very oily skin did you
have horrible acne when you when you
were a kid I didn't actually I mean it
was normal
acne but she's like you are super backed
up Jesus Christ backed up back up
was like nasty it sounds like I was like
is there stuff coming out cuz all I felt
was
pain she's like oh yeah I was like
G
nasty but uh anyway that was fun and
then we went to dinner but the big
surprise came on the way
home because I had been in preparing in
collaboration with
Lena we were um what's the word
conniving I don't know we were
conspiring conspiring sure um Lena was
at home during our outing setting up the
house because we got a yorky puppy
what and I knew I knew this was the best
president and she was going to love love
it but I had I I have had such mixed
feelings about it because I'm so in love
with shredder and I still think about
him and miss him so much mhm but I do
think it's important
to you
know in an act of it's not like
replacing him
it's it's a different
dog of course M I know but I just it's
like it's just a I don't know know I'm
very ambivalent I I the dog is amazing
he's so cute he's so sweet he's so
playful We call we named him ducky oh my
God ducky really isck so cute cute and
then um but he's so cute and sweet and
we tried which is not good advice I
don't advise it we knew it wasn't the
right thing to do but we let him sleep
in our bed and he took a fat
diarrhea in the middle of the night dude
and it was so nasty nice it was so nasty
and Alfredo was not down with that he's
like what the you doing you're
in the
bed oops but he's so sweet you guys can
meet him soon I didn't he's not ready
for prime time yet yeah I feel you um
here I I just took a little video wow I
didn't document it too much publicly but
I posted this
Oney of the doggies this was this was
happening when we were at dinner and I
was watching this and trying not to say
anything puppy
he's so he's so amazing he's so perfect
look how gentle and good Alfredo is he's
so
great yeah I don't know Fredo's been
kind of Grouchy though after this like
he I don't
know it took go ahead sometimes it takes
a second for the older dog yeah exactly
that's what I think too cuz he would
like this was really sweet but the rest
of the night you know how puppies are he
just wants to play play play play play
he's just like all energy and uh Alfredo
was just like not having it oh no
and pissing baby gotta love it
but he's doing great I mean he's already
peed outside a few times which is really
good he pooped outside so he's really
already making really good progress nice
puppy come
cute yeah he's so he's like perfect
perfect perfect yeah so great so was
great very cute name I love that thank
you so that was
there we go we're in it we're doing
it so how did Ela uh react she cried I
knew I knew it was going to be a it was
it was great he loved it great good yeah
I was very excited too I hadn't met
him you know mhm so oh and before you
come at me I donated $10,000 to a a dog
shelter okay so give me a wait what what
do you mean because people go oh you
bought a dog cuz he's a York you have to
buy oh bought it got it got it got it
from a breeder all right a very ethical
good
breeder um great care of him what but a
breeder nonetheless yes and we don't
believe in Eugenics around here even
when it comes to dog right we're going
to stop dissing the na but I feel like
you
know I'm like Bill Gates offsetting my
carbon emissions you know what I mean
you know how he does that he goes I yes
I apply my private jet but I I offset
emissions more than anyone he also drink
water so I mean yeah good guy okay
but so don't come at me okay um uh so
I'm people in the chat are asking and I
I I wondered myself what happened to the
cat idea um I'll tell you what happened
so I thought the kids were super into
the idea of the cat mhm and I asked
Teddy just to I just wanted to to hear
what he would say I said Teddy would you
rather have a dog or a cat expecting him
to say cat and he said dog huh he says
he wants a dog he doesn't want a cat
Okay and we were initially thinking that
we wanted to get a doggy friend for
alfredo and also I still have the um the
fear that I had before which is that our
doors our Outdoors are always open and
with kids coming and going right and we
live in like a ton of coyotes live yeah
that I would be absolutely uh
just uh paranoid obsessively about not
letting the cat out and God forbid if
the cat did get out it would be in
danger
right so we ended up I I just found the
these Yorkie puppies and they were just
H I knew that that that was it I knew
that was it so are you sure that this
isn't all cover for you having um
secretly cloned shredder like that uh
who was it was it Barb strian Barb
strian how she had the same dog for like
40 yearsing or something S no I didn't
clone shred I I would not do that I find
that very odd because then it really is
like trying to yeah that's cuz
it's not your dog that's not your dog
right it's a different dog right right I
want my dog
back I want my boy back I want
yeah a new version of him yeah yeah I
hear you no I didn't do that though is
that an option is that R is that an
option available to people yeah to just
clone yeah well what you do is that you
take their DNA and then I mean she did
that a while ago yeah I mean yeah I've
heard for about it for a long long
time hold on yeah can I clone my
dog your ven will collect a small tissue
sample from your dog this process is a
minor procedure tissue sample will then
be mailed to Via gen pets where we will
cultivate new cells that share the same
genetic makeup we will then freeze these
cells until you're ready to clone your
dog are you serious how much
does it cost to clone a dog 50,000 geez
Lise not for the um 50 not for the uh
basically for the for the very wealthy
clearly and so hopefully we'll be able
to clone our kids soon as well if we
didn't like the first sure how about
ourselves so that we can carry on
has Brian Johnson considered that but
it's not you if you clone yourself
you're still going to die it's me um
yeah do you know what I mean you're
you're not jumping bodies yes you're not
that's the thing also I would say this
you know how people talk about
immortality and like putting your brain
up in The Matrix or whatever uhuh that's
not you either what you're still dying
now we're drifting into a philosophical
discuss BR if you if your body dies and
brain is copied into the Matrix you're
dead that's just a new replica
of you br yeah it's a clone frankly a
mental clone what about
Chucky Chucky is an exception Chucky
like the murderer I don't know what you
mean by that you mean I assume you mean
well because right because the serial
Killer's Consciousness was transferred
to the doll right the back story Satanic
ritual yeah right okay but have you
considered uh satanism I have tried
everything to bring Shredder back oh
okay including uh seances the the laws
of transmutation and mhm I did a blood
sacrifice like Full Metal Alchemist Full
Metal Alchemist you turned somebody into
a horrific uh Chimera he came back as a
aulus I sucked I miss him I love him I
don't have any I it's according to this
you need some flesh which I don't have
Shredder's flesh with me
anymore well
I guess that ship sailed then that's
weird though to clone your dog that's
it's very odd that's weird it's very odd
you know it's
like I am seeing that Barbara Stan
uh they are they're Nam different I
don't think she treats them as if it's
an extension of the same dog I I think
she but it's still a
clone yeah it's like genetically
identical right it's genetically
identical which is it just seems kind of
unnecessary just get another dog I think
too you cuz like you said again it is
another dog live in yeah exactly love
again why go through all the trouble
here's the thing um how can you have a
genetically I understand you can
take so how does that work you implant
the egg inside the the dog to give birth
to so you don't use that dog's egg you
engineer the whole thing I yeah I mean
you'd have to then it wouldn't be
genetically identical yeah I don't know
yeah I imagine I don't know I imagine
that
uh I don't really believe in afterlife
but when if someday at the Pearly Gat
Shredder's up there waiting for
sure he'll be
there and I'll have a whole uh yorky
family uh it says uh somebody in the
chat said the cell samples need to be
from when the donor was younger
otherwise the DNA age will be messed up
so so does that mean that barbar was
planning this from the beginning hold on
ducky I need some flesh yeah
what like she if that's true she would
have had to have planned for that years
in advance sounds like it huh okay well
she's a planner but anyway that was the
birthday it was a really nice special
day that's nice glad you had a good
birthday he's
wonderful yeah he's a great beautiful
dog
so with that all being said there's only
one thing left to
do should we do stamps now to get it out
of the way and then I mean if you want
to get right into it yeah we should
probably just get the ad out of the way
they yelled at us once for doing it too
early yeah you guys like that I got
bitched out for doing it too early we're
almost at 20 minutes I think it's just
that it can't be in the first 10 I
believe listen there's too many people
watching in the first 10 and that's a
problem for our brand yeah I don't we're
going to need you to do a make good
don't really know the logic on that one
but uh I don't know that wasn't stamps
by the way we love stamps all right
let's do it let's do it okay we're at 20
minutes uh we're at 17 and a half so
let's just sit quietly for 2 minutes and
a half all right you want some music you
know what I've been doing though I'll
tell you what's that I since I played
Bor Gate 3 mhm and now I understand like
how that type of game is played which I
had no idea is this steep kind of
learning curve crpgs yeah C what's a
crpg uh I think it just stands for
computer role playing game but which
sounds really broad but it usually is
just referring to those kind of D and D
inspired types of games CU they're very
similar because so I went back and I
downloaded Divinity 2 on my uh game
Steam deck steam deck which I
can't Rave About Steam decks I'm gonna
have to get one I got to do it so I'm
playing VI Divinity 2 which is the game
that they made before bers gate right
and it runs on Ultra perfectly on the
steam deck it is just amazing and
um I started a game on the hardest
difficulty mhm because I was like I I
get this I got this and I'm and it's
just I've been every fight is a fight
for my life every fight is the hardest
fight in the game but it's so much fun
actually I'm I'm working my way slowly
through the first chapter but but it is
very fun and rewarding actuallyy it a
lot I mean this it might be a little too
retro for your taste but the original
balers Gates the old ones from the 9s
that was BioWare made those are Classics
for a reason they're really good
so if you want more of that i' I'd
suggest maybe check them out there
there's like a remaster that came out a
few years ago that modernizing and
everything yeah okay yeah but it's um
this is the same type of game it's the
same type of game it uses it's probably
even a little more complex than the new
one because it uses old school D and D
rules which were a lot more granular um
but it's got a great story and uh you
know it's the it's yeah generally it's
the same exact type of thing it's just
an old school version of it okay yeah
and you'll you'll you'll recognize a lot
of stuff because the it the the new one
was tied into it in a lot of ways right
yeah so there it is that's my video game
Journey for you guys as we sit on the
clock but okay let's think stamps.com 10
seconds actually
1950 uh here we go and in in five 4 3 2
sts.com
we love them thank you to stamps.com
who's been a great supporter of this
show the holidays are here people let's
not waste time let's do everything as
efficiently and good as possible and
that begins with stamps.com if you mail
anything if you're a small business if
you're just a hobbyist or even Dang if
you're a big business stamps.com has you
covered
convenience they send you a scale you
weigh your package you print the postage
you leave it either at the front door
cuz they'll come get it for you or you
can drop it off anywhere dropboxes post
office
whatever don't even think about going to
the post office especially this time of
year if you value your time as a human
being with finite time to live on this
Earth to love to feel to know to sit up
and not for the universe to know
itself we do not have time people mhm
very inconvenient yeah and the other
thing is the savings are
deep deep they are Deep Boy check this
out cuz they work with over a million
businesses they have massive negotiating
power 20 uh they've been business 25
years by the way
80 4% off
USPS and UPS wa
84 you have how who sent packages
recently you sent a package to the east
coast you're looking at 100 bucks if
it's like tangible like a thing with
like a little bit of weight sams.com is
going to get you the best deal 84% off
up to USPS and UPS rates also online
they've got automatically tells you the
cheapest and fastest shipping option to
make sure you're getting the best
deal and I don't know if I've mentioned
this but Dan's girlfriend is a Hu Ali is
a hug
huge proponent yeah I don't think we've
mentioned that but yeah she's uh used it
for years as her primary way of doing
her shipping for her online business and
it's been nothing but wonderful for her
she probably only pra from her on B yeah
only she've been using it for a long
time uh probably close to a decade now
wow wow because she sells online art and
I mean that's exactly what y stamps.com
is here it's why it exists how's her
business going is it good that these
people buy a lot of art from her they
they do and especially this time of year
for the holidays uh like commissions or
like posters uh both she does
commissions Uh custom commissions for
people but um she also just sells you
know stuff on her she has a Etsy and
that kind of stuff and she uses
stamps.com for all of it being a working
artist
rules yeah yeah it does and by the way
we we did a commission from her must be
nice why cuz I'm doing that you think no
because she gets to she works from home
she makes her own hours she yeah she
doesn't have a boss
oh come on Wow all right go draw Dan if
you love it so much if I could I would
yeah but I can't she actually made our
merch uh our merch she designed the uh
poster for this live show we can show it
I think we could show it sure why not um
let me put shirts and posters we always
do that at our lives we have a different
artist Comm yeah we've commissioned one
for each of the live shows and Ally did
this one allly made a really
wonderful uh graphic for us and I'm very
excited to present it to you guys now
but anyway thank you to stamps.com let
me just wrap this up here uh sign up
with the promo code H3 for a special
offer that includes a 4-we trial plus
free postage and a digital scale all of
that yes and there's no long-term
commitments or contracts it's easy peasy
lemon squeezy just go to stamps.com
Click the microphone at the top of the
page and enter the code H3 thank you to
stamps.com please consider supporting
them thank you to them yeah let me see
the graphic though yeah I am uh popping
it open right now let's see whoa I
actually haven't seen the Finish you
haven't seen the Finish that's sick here
it is and here it is guys presents the
steamies live the whole gang is here
Dolby
Theater awesome take a look at everybody
we got
love love we got Olivia we got Sam we
got Z dude you guys look awesome there's
a she even got my Les Paul in there
indeed that's dude that's Wicked
we got cam with the squirrel on his head
we got Ian Mr Mr verified yeah we got AB
with Anakin's uh uh lightsaber we got
Lena look how she Drew you she loves you
look at that look how she Drew you who
you me yeah oh baby blue eyes oh that's
Hazel actually she loves your blue eyes
yeah she got the and then Ethan and El
of course wearing their uh streamy
outfits yeah she she flat she flatters
me with that
she um but wow that's so yeah for
everybody attending in person oh yeah
the Addison R doll is in there as well
Addison Addison made it there there's
little tweaks we're doing like we're
going to round that back of it so that
uh for the shirt yeah there's a
different version for the shirt um oh I
I failed to point out uh all of uh Sam's
cursed food over here as well yes we
love and we love that about her don't we
sure do but yeah I mean shoot we
moved it up because we wanted uh keep
the show we moved from Friday today
because we want Friday show to keep a
little tight because Sunday is a huge
day for all of us and uh everybody is
buzzing with excitement are you guys
excited Sunday I mean wow I don't even
have time to be excited dude I've just
yesterday my uh I had a dentist
appointment in the morning and then I
got to the office at about 930 and I was
on the phone from that time until I left
at about 6 o00
just not backto back calls Logistics
calling this person talking to the
broadcast people talking to the venue
it's just like I was so sick talking
just remember just remember you guys are
the ones that wanted to do this I know I
know we always don't even you know I
just want to remind everybody I'm so
excited if it was up to me I would never
do anything
ever but you guys you guys forc the best
out of me it's YouTube's hottest night
it's YouTube I do love the the live
institution that we're we're building it
is very cool the academy it is it is it
is an academy and institution but I'm I
am looking forward to uh are you okay
Sam you good we started late cuz Sam got
a she cut hering bad your tips in your
pocket no you didn't show it to me do
you want me to take why is it in your
pocket did you C why is it in your
pocket wait how much did you cut off
stick your finger Sam says she has a tip
of her finger in her
pocket is it in there Raw it's not even
wrapped up what are you doing oh are you
gonna eat
it here come here I I got to see
[Music]
this s is bringing the tip of her finger
to show
me oh yeah that's a it's a good layer of
skin it was weird because there was like
one layer and then it had like a
core there was like uh there was a layer
of skin around it but then it had like a
white core like the meat you got a
little too deep yeah yeah and um how did
it happen I was just trying to cut like
a little hole in some fabric and I was
using fabric shears and it just like
sheared it
like it was so bad I can't it's like
stinging so bad it's like throbbing
right now Sam's been downstairs working
on our steamy
sets so working so hard they look so
good do you want I can get Jimmy to give
you pain meds
yeah can do that I can ask what he can
do for us you need a doctor though tell
you know what I mean you need a doctor I
don't think so I think I don't think
there's anything they can do no well you
could get well I don't know maybe just
like to disin we did disinfect
disinfected it yeah we all we all jumped
up and you know made sure it we did a
whole Tre yeah we did we did yeah
everyone nursed me back to help I guess
if you're in immense pain they could
give you painkillers yeah although most
of the time they'll just give you moin
which is just ibuprofen I don't need
that they don't they don't really give
out opioids anymore yeah my fingers are
thanks uh what's the what's the name of
that thanks sackers can't even get
Viking in anymore cuz you
thanks for checking on me I'm good
okay thank you and well done good work
keep it up not the finger cutting part
but the everything else you're doing
yeah the rest is
great um
yeah okay so well what else is
there to say or do except just hop right
in let's get it done guys it is time at
long
last to
Crown 2023 is winner of the sound bite
tournament it's YouTube's most exciting
night day can we look take a
retrospective who are our previous
winners in the pane on of
greatness uh I we had just looked up
last year's um and the the final winner
what was it Ian I'm blanking who won
last
year we were looking at it yesterday but
my mind's Ino was shout out to the
family no no no no I believe it was
Assan Adolf Hitler dude no that was the
runner up oh I remember that family uh
2022 no is it hoe guys we need you know
like and L AK and like when the Lakers
play they they retire the jerseys we
need an
award and a in a permanent
fixture to honor the
winners so work on that list I'm going
to start because we have so much to do
but I want to see that list and then we
need to we need to actually Crown them
I'm I'm going through right now and yeah
the first one was shout out to the
family was the
first it was how I just I pulled up last
year
wait oh wait really
yep the prolapse one mhm huh that was a
big moment about it what do we do about
it what do we do about it I didn't't
heard a lot of those this
year well maybe it was wait we've we've
done it more than twice haven't we uh we
did one I think the second one well
5% 5% won one of them yeah yes that was
the winner for the second one 5% so is
this this is our third one or fourth one
this is the fourth one okay so we had
shout out to the
family I think 5% was the year after
that mhm Howe Mel last year yep and
today the new winner remains to be voted
on yep give us a playthrough Zach of our
previous year's winners what do we do
about it
ow wonderful when my friend Neil bent
this
happened a wonderful time a wonderful 5%
I love that one so much it's to me still
funny shout out to his family we only
need to do 28 more and then we could do
a super bracket wa we actually you know
we might make it we might make it 28
years how old will I be in 28 years uh
well you're 42 now 43 I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I know you're sensitive
about that so plus how many do we need 6
uh 66 you say 26 Ian you need 28 more 28
28 more so be 66 I mean that that's a
good age to retire I could go out and S
you guys plan on being around for
another 30 years oh for sure oh yeah oh
yeah I mean what else you know why not
what else am I
doing well you got to work I agree I'm
working for at least 30 years forever 28
years that's it that's our goal I won't
retire I'll just work until I drop dead
thanks I well when are you planning on
retire me 66 I just said I'm not
retiring I'm just saying I need you to
serve at least until you're cuz you're
two years younger than me right or a
year younger than me uh You' be 65
that's a perfect age I'm two years
younger than you yeah 64 great you're
out early perfect
okay you're just in time for the early
bird special so you cana Vista all
right excuse me let's do it guys
the brackets are established let's pull
them
up the year is 2023 there are some
strong strong contenders this year and
to be honest I can't
name a specific favorite I can't see the
bracket oh I'll pull it up stand by so
the first bracket
here is two really strong contenders
right at the top that's dude to put
these two in here so could have been
finalists uhhuh oh no you know tipster
cheers my dude has a lot of power this
year coming into the end of the year
Zach has truly championed The Sound by
and it and he's won all of our hearts
with it as well I'm not actually maybe a
sh what you can say you can put a
prediction out we've we've seen in the
past that the predictions actually don't
predict that out um I just want to say
this is my f there's so so many there's
so many great ones this has such a
tremendous impact and and it's quick
it's I add it to my quick keys because
it's so versatile cheers my dude love
you no homo I mean it doesn't get better
than that that's a tall boy too oh yeah
so that's our boy big tip and I I also
think that he's a very strong Contender
but he's up against calling me
right which is a good one I don't know
if it's well okay so there's a double
entry here we had to consolidate some in
the interest of you know being it's
better I think it's more fair and it's
more tight so here's me right by
Colleen me right yeah that one gets
a lot of play too I yeah I mean I don't
want to Poison the Well too
much tipster is that's my
goat our boy that's that's who I'm roing
for to make it all the way but I
wouldn't be surprised if it gets knocked
out right here in the first round by
colen cuz she's a juggernaut she's a
juggernaut she had a huge year she had a
huge year here's the other one that's
being bundled up which is the um fart
joke predor even though a lot of you
think so because 5 years ago I made a
fart
joke it's a funny way to put it that's
like o OJ's like cuz 20 years ago
I got a little mad
once you know what I mean I lost my
temper you know what I mean don't we all
do that oh you you you'd be surprised
how many girls got father issues Jesus
CHR didn't make the board actually this
year but you know what I mean but anyway
guys let's get the polls open we've got
tipster we've got Colleen it's the first
bracket let's start buzzing through all
right round one here we go we have
tipster
cheers my
dude versus colen I think me right
yeah I don't know for me it's seems like
a it's me right slash me right
fart joke a fart J fart joke I do like
fart
joke as well all right I'm going to yeah
I I'll have them queued up in the future
okay sweet thank you getting it going
right now love you no homo so here's the
here's the first poll we have big tip
verse uh fart joke oh yeah and that's I
mean the thank God the exit pole is
showing what we all thought was just
cheers my dude is making a huge powerful
right out oh I'm so glad to see that I
mean that's what I expected you 70 it's
just I really thought
Colleen she just she has so much pull to
me this is this is a a winner potential
so I'm not surprised that tipster came
out F Furious and making a statement why
people saying the pull blank pull blank
don't worry about them this is right
blank pull
I mean I'm seeing a lot of people say
that we do poll it's broken what is
wrong with all of your computers 8,000
votes
everybody it's fine I see what's
happening here 73% for big tip and
congratulations he's he's advancing
there's no problem there there's no
question huh okay I didn't think so I
didn't um I guess if you're not if it's
the people that are saying it's broken
are you on mobile and if so maybe you
need to update your uh app or something
I I don't know why so many people would
have it broken like that all right let's
keep going got C now this is this is one
that I personally love but I think that
I might
be
somewhat in a minority group here this
was the year of the uh monologues I feel
I love the monologues there's a lot of
them so this is Charlie going on and on
about the cookie Scandal um which was as
you
know uh a Monumental moment up
yeah it it it changed my perception of
the year and here so here's Charlie uh
talking about Pokemon's cookie
controversy the success rate of like $28
no matter how you spend this is a lot
for some cookies and I think the
way she keeps trying to break it down
and rationalize it is pretty
disingenuous it's $7 a bag and that's
still expensive but then you also have
to factor in that the bags aren't even
big to begin with it's 4 o bag 4 oz of
cookies for $7 is still a lot especially
when you compare it to the the product
that they're basing it off of and
supposedly approved upon the Tooty
Midnight Cookies those were $10 a bag
for 14 o so even though the toy Midnight
Cookies were $3 more per bag they
offered you 10 o more of product and
they were sold in Costco a lot of people
really enjoyed them but most people
didn't like the price that was a pain
point of that $10 for a bag of cookies
is a lot so $7 for a smaller bag of
cookies significantly smaller is a lot
too like it it doesn't matter how you
boil down this math all roads lead to
this being an expensive product that's
the brass tax of it that is the hard
pill to swallow true it's hard it's hard
for me to accept it it is it is an
expensive cookie way of spinning
this of these cookies isn't expensive it
is and to try and call people broke for
not buying it or not being able to
afford it is really some out of touch
and the really it is so thank you
Charlie for breaking down the the
logistics I love that one I love it
personally it's just so much hubbub over
the dumbest thing this man went straight
to the Blackboard he's doing like
hardcore like calculus on the on the
Blackboard like Goodwill Hunting
yeah what love is he yapping bro were
you saying something no oh just yapping
just yapping he's yapping about the
yapping however
ab and preach had a big year this is oh
God I love this one this one is one of
my favorites so ab and preach this is a
bundle this ISS remember when we used to
burn the witch and break those eggshells
so first let me play Yeah there
something that we're
missing whenever we talk about burning
the witch
preach you know the era where we used to
burn the witch yep that era never really
stopped oh the type of witch we was
burning
wait we're literally burning people
alive cuz I don't know if you know that
but they actually were burning people
alive right so when you say that never
stopped I'm assuming that's what you
mean so see him cry like that so that
was that one I love that one yeah a good
one it's so good but here this is the
one that I love this one I can't
lie the eggshells and in order to
comprehend you're going to have to break
some comprehend in order to compr and to
eat the the the the omelet of knowledge
you're going to need to break those
eggshells and it's going to cause a
bunch of problems and you're going
to have the courage to break that shell
yeah so in order to comprehend we have
to the in order to
comprehend so that is uh the those
eggshells
eloquent uh reach mhm or no absolutely
really nice performance so these are
great I I don't know there there is
going to be a clear winner here I just
started the uh poll and uh yeah as
predicted let me throw it on oh that's
aod you know what I can't even I agree I
mean the Aban preach one is so damn good
so good burning the I can't actually I
can't even put that on Abba I mean
that's just that's just a preach
exclusive those eggshells yeah so um ab
and preach taking at 84%
God so thank you critical for the great
entry but you are outdone my friend by
some of the best in the biz right and
there it is God I'm already looking at
this next round and my God this is like
this is that's that one be choice right
here
T I wonder if we should do it now cuz
it's all on the no no no no there's
there's rules there's protocols you're
right you're right we can't change the
rules already rules you sons of
all right next bracket we've got Gizzy
overdrive
versus DJ C tell him to bring out the
whole ocean I love that khed one that's
a strong one this year khed is so back
dude he's so
cappuccino dude he's just he's blowing
up on Instagram everyone is
rediscovering the joy of khed I I think
his shtick now is super funny I'm not I
think it's like not even ironically
funny I think it's just straight up he's
doing I think he knows it too he seems
to have just embraced theud he's he's
played into that cappuccino one's crazy
likeo and he goes he goes
Cino together we're stronger together
we're stronger he goes and what is this
water
cappucino so anyway here's Gizzy
overdrive friend of the show a great guy
we love him shout out the gbba so good
than of the ice cream think of the heart
me I H you too than of
thees
100 glizzies and dring Gizzy
[Music]
overdrive increasing grip by
7% we are locked in thank you for over
160 glizzies and doing Gizzy
[Music]
Overdrive that is such a great moment I
mean this was a nice Arc I loved having
him on the show yeah I loved the um I
love his whole thing so that's Gizzy
over it's good to play in uh moments
where you wouldn't expect to hear him
you do you sneak them in he really
people shouldn't forget the just one
that you do can you do a little oh
yeah yeah that one that one tears down
the house quite frequently it's a banger
yeah so that's Gizzy bot friend to the
show and DJ C incidentally also a friend
of the show right tell him to bring out
the whole ocean DJ C's Big Year to bring
out the whole
ocean tell him to bring out the whole
ocean I think this was the first one
this is the one that created this what
kicked it off yeah tell him to bring out
the whole o he just kept saying the same
thing bring out the whole ocean I'm not
a food guy so but to me that looks
so gross I I guess people like seafood
looking I say tell him to bring out the
whole ocean it's not just that he keeps
repeating it but he is the inflection is
identical it's like he is a sound AR
it's so bizarre he's saying exactly the
same every time what an ear on that guy
tell him to bring out the whole ocean
let him
know through the side of his
mouth look at that lobsters that does
look from Bahamas it looks you guys
don't like lobster I don't eat seafood
anymore but when I when I was a kid I
love Lobster that looks delicious I
frankly I find it really chewy and just
weird and I don't know I I but again I'm
not I'm very Seafood opposed for
whatever reason like I can eat fish but
anything beyond that like crustations or
shellfish or anything just ain't about
it octopus I can't touch any of that
stuff having a hard time cut
they're too alien mhm oh he loves it
though Cal loves it God did God did what
God did the other one that I think is
worth watching is him being like and
what is
this and and this and perhaps here
here's and perhaps this right and
perhaps this though that is DJ
khed I never play those right it's true
we do like that but oh okay there it is
then all right so I'm going to throw up
uh round three here so we got Gizzy
overdrive mhm versus khed bring out the
whole ocean this one could go either way
frankly the gzy one very versatile khid
however huge
year uh the votes are stream are flowing
in tell to bring out the whole massive
dumps so apparently if you change your
uh light to light mode on on mobile
you'll see the text cuz it's white or
black on black on dark dark mode oh it's
a dark mode then yeah so if you change
it to light mode apparently some people
have said they can see it again uh huh
yeah maybe give that a shot if you're on
mobile and you still can't see the polls
uh it sounds like it might be a bug in
the YouTube app thank you Ian I guess
this this doesn't factor into the voting
but just for to for Old Time sake to
remember the year that we've enjoyed
this is called what that's just avocado
that's no that's just avocado
tub what turkey sauce this is called
what turkey PR and this is called what
scr and what is this pickled banana
peppers and what is this berries and
seed and perhaps what is this
[Music]
water Sunday morning Sunday brush like
why does he talk like that I don't know
but I love
it I don't know he's adopted this whole
like persona it's awesome that's just
avocado I love how she that's just
avocado toast everybody knows what that
is but also I love his fruit portion
it's like three
[Laughter]
blackberries at least it's there yeah
well the people have spoken we're
looking at a blowout Gizzy a Gizzy
blowout this does see this is the
closest one so far but still a clear
winner here 60% Gizzy 40% CID true that
it was close but our friend uh Gizzy
bot is taking a lead and moving on to
the next bracket so congratulations I'm
happy for him frankly as a as a viewer
of the show I'm happy for
him light mode working for people guys
change to light mode apparently change
to light Mode YouTube is on their
always but at what what cost you're
going to get go blind light mode
universally uh reviled yeah everyone
hates that so up
next we've got a huge Trump packet aha I
think this was the year of trump sound
bites he had some heaters well what's
funny because he was not even in the
spotlight this year like next year is
going to be the Trump year yeah well
don't forget that earlier there was that
like two-month period of time earlier
this year where he got arrested like
four
times
true so he he did have a decent amount
of uh exposure this year that's true so
here is um the first one shut up silly
woman shut up silly woman shut up silly
woman shut up what's the context there I
don't remember is he just telling
someone to shut up probably not it's
probably no he was maybe even was
quoting somebody this is a you can do it
baby I love you this iconic I mean she
and just bad news bad things that happen
this one's
crazy mom I'm
sorry Mom I didn't do a that one is so
good
honestly he gets so into character dude
he's he's halfway to being at the at the
bank of a river with his grandma's pubes
brushing upon his
face
no uh here's him uh turn up the mic oh
this is this is just this is the worst
microphone I think I've ever had I hope
you can hear me back
there Justin don't pay the bill for this
mic I'm blowing out my voice talking to
this stupid mic this the worst mic I've
ever had okay now we'll get back to the
speech I'm trying to get their attention
turn up the
mic sounds like an audio system is it
okay and then I don't pay a bill and
they say Trump doesn't pay his
contract it's unbelievable it's a yeah
you still pay you still owe the money
bro the state of it but it's not my deal
deal it's not my deal I have a good mic
I always have you don't have a good mic
it's a very difficult deal you walk out
for tough for two weeks you're talking
say what the hell happened to his voice
the state of Israel is a blessing to the
world prayers are with them now in this
Terri so um he's having mic issues
clearly oh we we religiously uh quote
that around the office turn up the mic
turn up the mic
this is the worst mic I've ever had by
the way I want to say he is notorious
for not paying people but I find it
funny cuz he's like I'm a man of the
people and this here mik these sound
people are never getting paid by me
because the mic was quiet turn the world
that's f up dude anyway here is uh it's
100° here for the Press it's about 110
Dees of this room nice job with the air
conditioning
whoever
but you know what the Press will say you
know what the they'll say Trump didn't
look well he was extreme wet it's 104 or
5° in this great sir but we're okay with
it right you look great sir we're all
very and we're all rooting for
you um Don't Call Him a fat pig this one
was really something about Chris
Christie he's defending his dear friend
Chris Christie against a fat shaming
and he's a good man for that here he is
Chris's he's eating right now he can't
[Applause]
be the same rally perhaps it looks like
looking extremely wet
yeah sir please do not call him a fat
pig that's very disres don't call
him see I'm I'm trying to be nice Don't
Call Him a fat pig you can't do you
can't do that that's the president so
because you're not allowed to do that
and therefore we're not going to do it
okay that part is so funny people
thought that George Bush Jr was crazy
the he would say but like Trump is
really setting the bar to a new oh it's
yeah there's no comparison yeah it's the
the my political enemies they're fat
pig the bushisms are are quaint in cute
yeah quaint real sorry um and then here
is the honestly this is pretty much the
Crown Jewel I mean this is the real one
in my opinion I did everything right and
they indicted me and so far has not what
the is this miced I did everything
right and they indicted me why is now
that's a bad M that's the worst mic that
he's ever had you don't hear him
complaining there yeah yeah I seem to
remember that a bunch of the feeds were
up on this one I did everything
right and they indicted me I did
everything right and they indicted me
[Music]
well here we go I
mean EXC I'm tired cuz I had to wake up
at before I have to changed my whole
bedding oh God right and then we set up
the dog pin too cuz we're like he's not
ready yeah yeah that's Mom I'm sorry so
that whole Trump packet versus Howe
Mandel our very own champion from last
year's champion and who graced us this
June
and dropped the new one here it is show
us child pornography right let's
see she's the only one that understands
the game show us child
pornography D we got him so good thank
God God he's such a legend tuning in
leaning into it you know oh he we got
him so such a good sport we got him so
good for that that was my mom I think
set him up for that one mom the funniest
guesses now hey
Howie yes I just want to let you know
Soul's no longer asking to move on and
that's what bothers
me that is concerning sa are you
okay there's police outside he said move
on until she brought up child
pornography and he went this is
good this is the clickbait how I want to
tell you something did I just get
canceled no but you just just get sound
bited yep and there it is I felt that
immedi that this was I got you
I got you that is going to
be he did us a great a really gracious
favor showing up and we got him though
we got wow so I mean this round is
another heater round I don't know I
don't know so you have the whole Trump
sound uh set although I would really
Crown Jewel is I did everything right
and they died yeah that's the that's the
bang I did everything right and they
indicted show us child pornography is so
good okay this is a close one oh yes it
is we are off to a tight race here
everybody you're going to want to get
your vote in cuz right now it's 52%
audio Trump audio package versus
48% how we show us child pornography God
this is close this is like final round
close show us it is not budging we have
5,600 votes people show us 51% is tight
oh wow it is tightening 51 to 4
woman I'm trying to get their attention
turn up I'll keep it going but right now
it's 50 oh it's teetering 52
51 it sure is close though Hoy Mandell
fans get your votes in show me child I
got to say stop saying child P we're
going to get yeah right yeah oh Trump
show us Trump is actually inching ahead
now
53% wow Tak lead we have 11,000 votes
I'll I'm going to lock this up in I
think we can lock it up frankly shut up
we'll give it another thousand let's
give it another little bit here but it
does look like Trump is just stagging
out our boy hoe it's about 110 degrees
in this room yeah well wow okay you know
I didn't really know where which
direction this was going to go I thought
Howie might have a I mean Howe was close
and I do love that sound bite well
unfortunately this is probably a little
preview of next year's election let's
wrap up this poll here oh you think
Trump is gonna win he's heading all the
polls significantly now so far a year is
a long way from now yeah he might be in
jail by then so exact that might that
might impact I don't think that'll
affect his numbers might help yeah Trump
took an he just took another point in
the in the battle here so we're going to
lock it up thank you 15,000 votes wow
okay Trump audio package takes the win
with
54% sorry Howie I know you were really
rooting for that sound by to be
immortalized child pornography but we
will always we will always
remember extremely wet here's a fun
bracket fidus it's interesting huh
versus death bell sound immortalized by
Mitch
McConnell's when he saw the um we got
some good ass sound bites this year I
got to say it was a good year every year
is just full of just it's just such
tapestry of just fantastic cultural
moments so here's fidus our new
Fascination we love
him like I didn't have a relationship
after you but I'm I'm glad I didn't
because uh I don't know it it wasn't a
priority I mean you obviously Miss
connection and affection in that way but
it's
okay it's interesting
when uh when you have multiple relation
no multiple relation I mean I had you
and then I was with Olia it's
interesting how you
compare how you comp when another new
person potentially comes in the your
life like you compare what we did is she
more beautiful is she more cool is she
more loving is
she like did you have this as well how
did she I did did she understand
anything he just said I mean over
context was pretty wild too he's like
yeah no it's interesting how when I got
a new girlfriend I was like she's cooler
she's
hotter I also uh I guess to add to this
it's from that same uh video I come
through the whole thing to find his best
moments of mumbling which is what
addition to that main one I play this
this uh is also up for vote as the same
package and go ahead because this one is
phenomenal
I I know but to answer the thing I don't
I don't like this one is so versatile
it's so much fun I don't up with anybody
I love talking with our conversations
are always super
engaging I have about four to catch up
and talk and like see how each other is
doing not in messages or video call like
in real life oh no we didn't meet
through video call okay I can reach out
and talk for yeah do you even email me
time and like catch up but it's kind of
not how I want you can text or email I
don't know it's it's interesting but it
felt kind of
wrong
to
up God it's so funny F was really um
such a surprise too how we stumbled upon
his podcast Channel live on the on the
show uhhuh and it just was such a fun
the butts
podcast he's live right now actually
he's doing a 14-day Marathon we noticed
he's it's only 3 every time I po in he's
asleep 22 uh people are watching it's me
I popped in there yesterday on the
podcast YouTube account and started
screaming at him to get up I saw that
was so funny wake up wake up F ass but
there's 22 people watching day 14 he's a
VR headset for 30 days straight I mean
I'm not going to lie it's kind of a cool
experiment it's interesting it's
interesting but he's just always asleep
but oh there you go what's weird is he's
live streaming this to his 2.5 million
subscriber Channel I don't know if this
I think this could have been
edited because there's 20 people
watching you and I think it's all just
been a continuous thing it's interesting
wait was he driving
in the prev
thumbil hold on I mean what's the
problem you can
see here let's see no he's not he's
driving no he's got to be he's in the
passenger seat yeah he has a driver we
looked earlier thank God okay okay me it
is bro okay good how's he doing on how
do you call
it it's interesting they all talk like
that everyone in his life was like uh
look the stars and like
wow it's been one and a half year dude
he's been sleeping a long time this is
from
25 I guess it's just two hours wait this
how long is this live going then cuz
this like 30 days I think so he's
moving oh he's stirring yeah it's not
fake he's actually doing yeah no he's in
there fidus would he's the real deal say
what you will
but well now he has 43 so wake up
everyone's saying wake upake up wake up
wake up videous wake up uh what do
change like something things that change
in your
mindset is inter so first it was you
were the first person to kind of on my
my life I was like it's good to share
moments
with do all like I love the having a
person to talk when you're down when
you're are like having like sometimes
when I'm alone I miss this this is one
of the things that I I me like just
laying there and like what hugging like
just so many problem all right FAS thank
you so much uh strong ENT I love the
contrast too it cracks me up because
like all these like podcast clips that
we found of him like mumbling like that
but then his like video
he's doing like the style thing and like
he still has an accent but he's like
yelling he's enunciating and everything
and and somehow when you go into podcast
mode he just loses all of that I think
it's
just it's rehearsed he has more time he
prob does a bunch of times he's he
energizes it he uses all his energy in
his videos he doesn't have any left for
the damn podcast got to chill out fair
you know uh he's sleeping the whole time
damn wake up wake up idiot it's fidus
versus finishing the Mitch McConnell
seeing the Death Note demon in the
audience here it is this week has been
good by partisan
cooperation and a string of
[Music]
uh the joke of course was that he saw
the Grim
Reaper and the audience saying MIT it's
time
your soul is
mine we made a deal years ago are you
good did you forget okay Mitch I'm here
to collect Mitch anything else you want
to say I'm sure let go back to your I'm
waiting he just gives up let's go back
to he's still he's still serving right
yes sir yeah he's the
man between him and Joe Biden what's the
median age
n's in her 80s although yeah she's still
up she's she's up the top the most
powerful people in the world have a
medium a or in the United States have a
median age of like 85 yeah it's
awesome great so anyway let's let's see
this is real interesting stuff we got
fidus vers the M McConnell death to Nell
yes indeed I am throwing up the
pole tolls for thee go
yeah this is I love them both
frankly
interesting I'm actually surprised I'm
not I thought it was going to lean the
other way death bell sound is winning
resoundingly wow 65% and I'll tell you
why this bell sound is just prolific
it's so funny every time it transforms
the moment right no matter what it is
the Bell is a powerful powerful
Contender I agree I agree Zach is uh
he's he's like a surgeon with that thing
and I mean listen fidus is fantastic so
the Bel I think it's just a a testament
to the bell's strength wow yeah wow it's
like not even close again I will say
this is the year of the monologue mhm
this Bell is very iconic and it can be
used in anything true a lot of utility a
lot of utility you even use it whenever
we talk about Taco
Bell there the bell I want Taco Bell oh
this this might be long enough for two
meals did we order we did we did what's
the ETA they give ETA says between 157
and
207 okay so about a half hour from now
you think they're telling the truth
though well they've pushed it a few
times so I I hope that this is keepe
have to order Taco Bell next Oh Boy
Might Taco Bell's fast right uh sort of
no it's not no they they're fast they're
the fast as once I guess it's just it's
such a crap with the I don't know
oh anyway I see people uh saying about
the my poll is blank we addressed this
earlier apparently it is a bug on the
YouTube mobile app that some people have
found a workaround that if you turn off
dark mode it fixes it so if you are in
dark mode right now on your phone and
you're not seeing the polls try turning
that off go to light mode and
theoretically it should fix it dude
YouTube is so it's literally it
keeps going between 40 and 30,000
viewers like what do you mean uh I've
been keeping an eye on that so the ACT
ual um like chart is consistent but the
concurrent viewer count keeps
fluctuating by like tens of thousands so
so annoying I think it's just bugged so
what is it at on your end uh I'm seeing
37k okay yeah that's where it was at
yeah okay so I mean I love the Bell I'm
happy for the Bell fous maybe next year
we we're going to stay tuned for sure
yeah so keep the good content up
especially the podcast and I'm sure
we'll we'll get you back in there again
before too long but congratulations to M
McConnell still alive the he's left the
Grim Reaper on red you know it's funny
I'm seeing in the
chat obviously the Bell won and won
resoundingly the the fitus fans they are
incensed by this I noticed that there's
a there's people with strong opinion
saying the Bell is overrated and people
saying fidus was robbed but this is
democracy in action this is what we do
here and I mean the votes continue to
rise and the percentages are not
changing at all which tells me that and
this is the will of the people fidus is
very funny so I know what where they're
coming from and I feel like it with some
people it really
connects but uh for me I I would vote
for the bell I think I actually and I'm
unable to vote because I'm logged in as
the account but anyway uh
congratulations
deathbell the death bell
Nell and uh ooh the next bracket really
exciting to me Steven Crowder that
doesn't work for me either watch it
versus Boogie a late entry but a strong
entry I never
did and the whole
interview boogies might have a big year
this year his are insanely good but
here's Crowder I never did what do you
need me to pick up I'll get it I'll be
back when I'm back this is actually work
either yeah I'm not the whole video is
actually quite sad yeah the but we we we
forget about the sad context and we like
to enjoy just this moment of him
sounding like a baby you made me what do
you need me to pick up I'll get it I'll
be back when I'm back no that doesn't
work either it doesn't work either God I
forgot just how wow such a I can't
believe that's the context to that silly
coot she got I just need the car cuz I
need I just need to run some errands
that doesn't work either that doesn't
work either
why are people saying F what are we
effing for no it froze for a second but
it seems better now what happened it
seem like it was bu people are saying F
oh they're back yeah we back YouTube
what's going on with YouTube today bro
seriously what is
happening dumbass idiots um I don't know
we may have uh we may have missed the
context on the Crowder then if we were
out that doesn't work oh for real should
I I'll watch it again I mean just yeah
so Crowder in case we missed it uh
doesn't work
either one more time for the people who
what do you need me to pick up I'll get
it I'll be back when I'm back no that
doesn't work either you'll be back when
you're back either we definitely had a
really good time with this one and it
just it really shows just what a
he is that doesn't work either he really
how does he how can anybody respect this
man at this point I don't know that many
blows my mind I know he has fallen off
significantly because of that but um
watch it I I know and these are
traditional value people and but also
like they're Al these are guys like men
are alphas and women are submissive and
it's like dude he sounds like a doesn't
work he's a whiny
child doesn't either um so that's
Crowder's entry Boogie is however
tipping the scale not and I that's not a
joke about his way dude I just mean like
in a competition sense of course TI he's
tipping the SK looking at it you're the
I quote to you said it you said that I
said that and I never did
I I never did I never did did I never
did I never did I never did I never did
but you said I did that's you being
wrong about me that's you being wrong
about me that is Boogie Deni he denies
it whatever it is I never did I never
did has really infected my brain I say
that to Ally all the time when I wish
you you know what Zach I wish you played
that one
more I think I play he plays it a decent
cuz I just love it so much make it
Sparks joy in
me that being
said I'll be like Zach why don't you
ever play or no how do I make Zach why
don't you never not play that sound
butt I had to do a double negative for
it to work which doesn't make a lot of
sense but you're I never did okay we
tried but that's not the real entry for
me the real entry is the Boogie
interview clip and boy howdy is this a
monologue because you are seeking
employment yeah you're seeking out new
work opportunities absolutely tell me a
little bit about this to me is like one
of the best things of all time I mean
this is internet history background and
where you think you want to go with the
experience that you already have um I
did work at a small gaming store back
in 2006 2007 I am disabled uh recognized
by the state of Arkansas but also the
United States government there's that
now the downside to that is I am
extremely depressed so there's some
mental health issues that we bring to
the table and then physically I I am
morbidly obese I have no references uh
no work history and no education and
when you gole my name I didn't even
notice her
face he didn't and wait he didn't even
tell you the best part
lady you might see rumors that I beat my
ex-wife and I'm also a pedophile should
mention I'm also a felon okay uh is that
all I mean what it's left also I
currently have dead bodies in my now
like what how do you top that I never I
don't know okay he might be the most
unemployable person alive he might be
right about that also I love her
unaffected okay okay dude I don't know
how she played that off two years that's
crazy so that I me and I'm also a
pedophile me is that the part that
gets you though when he says the the
pedophile well because it just gets
worse and worse and worse and you don't
think it can get worse but it does
because I beat my wife oh yeah also
people they might be saying that I might
be a pedophile as well that that's which
is the worst thing you can be pretty
much I play the monologue quite a bit
but the one I I out of that I play the
pedophile sound bite the majority of the
time yeah I it's just it's a masterpiece
I mean you couldn't write it out in a
funnier Better Way
pedophile so I mean here it is it's
Crowder vers Boogie all right throwing
it up um you know here we go no that
doesn't work either I mean to me I have
a favorite but I'll wait I think it's I
think it's obvious though which no well
Crowder's getting some love it's not all
a blowout
here actually it's quite close it's
60% Boogie my ex-wife and Crow's got
some 40% Crowder and then physically I
mean Crowder does have a lot of utility
though he Zach busts out the watch it a
lot watch it also the the no like I just
play the no that doesn't work I play the
No No doesn't work either so okay I
thought this would be a boogie blowout
however I see that there's a lot of
passionate Crowder fans in the audience
41% shout out to all the Crowder fans
who watch the H stre
podcast PE uh Li overlap there she's in
the minority every time well this is
this is democracy in action my friends
you voted that's all that matter
democracy manifest I mean it's
tightening still 42% Crowder although
it's really not close enough I think to
I never did to extend I never did I
never did yeah with 10,000 votes we're
going to call it 58% Boogie but well
done Crowder actually making put up a
fight a valiant put up he put up a fight
phenomenal entry by Crowder any other
Year my friend any other isn't that one
of his like slogans like fight like hell
fight like hell yeah he fought like hell
I don't know as us he lost fight your
wife like hell yeah fight your fight
your wife to prevent her from getting
the car keys I should mention I'm also
Fen about 2 years you know I haven't
ended it yet and Crowder keeps going
up should we maybe keep it going another
minute here
43% he's on the ride I don't think it's
possible 57 it's a big gap to overcome
you're right I mean there's already
14,000 votes but every time I look at it
he he's up another Point Let's see I'll
wait till 15,000 votes and
see I don't think statistically it's
even possible from the it's very
unlikely it's just uh he does
have some momentum but probably not
enough to overcome 44 it's
oh God right see it keeps moving in that
direction Crowder fans are entering the
building they're flooding in from Rumble
they heard that he's up and they want to
support their boy everybody who's seen
who's been showed Crowder's penis
against their will is in the voting
Lobby right now making their voices
heard and there's a lot of them it could
tip the scale
actually but I
mean as close as it is now it's 44%
Crowder 56% Boogie I think we got to
wrap it up okay it's a valiant effort
that's effort he fought like hell fought
like hell he can be proud of
that very
good up
next Jesse Lee Peterson's gay
rant which is a beloved one I still
waiting I still really want to meet him
I'm sure he would have you on his show
well you gay I don't want to reach out I
he should he should ask me I feel like
it does feel weird to contact him to go
on show let's be maybe he does maybe
maybe he doesn't like me I'm really I
had no idea I keep mentioning him nobody
nobody like Jesse I'm begging you please
I want to collab with you you don't look
gay so anyway his homophobic Rants and
then versus loves where's my schuma
loomas wow that's massive that's quite a
category this is interesting so you a
gay I'm gay I didn't know you gay yeah
well I just told you how did you become
gay one doesn't become gay one is born
that way does God know you're gay I
believe so did he make you that way I
that's my opinion you think that God
Made You Gay I have no you know I don't
I don't know the I'm not going to be
presumed to uh
uh uh Plum the depths of the of the most
high but yes I've I've been gay as long
as I can remember and so have you been
with men of course I I like he's such a
fascinating interviewer I don't think
anybody does interviews like him it's
just it's so fascinating to watch and
it's entertaining as hell even though
obviously he's a demon but he's all but
almost like he's so silly it's almost
like non-threatening demonic Pres well
and there's
also fairly from what I understand
substantiated rumors that yeah it
closeted or or or in denial or I don't
know how you want to Define it but there
there there's a lot of Buzz about him
yeah having amazing homosexual relations
so yeah yep that adds another bizarre
angle to the whole thing yep TR yes
really yeah this is mind blowing for you
why is that because I never expected a a
priest and a father of Epiphany Church
to be gay that you're sounds like you're
coming from the Assumption what what's
look gay mean you know Swit and soft
looking really that's what you call
stereotyping that's called uh that's
like if I were to say to you and what's
interesting too about these
conversations like you cannot get
through to him his points are so bad
they're so
and no matter how hard you counter him
he doesn't listen he just comes at you
harder the same question yeah are you a
man are you a man and then you go like
well you okay are you a man well I don't
know I mean what do you mean by that
like do you mean like that I'm a male or
do you mean like are you a man are you a
man it's
awesome so that's Jesse we love him I
love him I don't know about you guys
they're all like there more to that clip
we we don't have to play but there's
some like really oneoff weird
in there so you okay should I keep
watching I Love It
know and a father of Epiphany Church to
be gay that you're sounds like you're
coming from the Assumption what look you
know switch and soft looking really
that's what you call stereotyping oh
that's called uh that's like if I were
to say to you well you're black where's
your Fried Chicken oh brother he went
there huh wow
well I guess that is that is an example
of stereotyping at the house and I can't
wait to get home to eat
it so you know that's amazing so are
your does do your congregation know that
you're absolutely they do that is mind
blowing and so you think that God make
mistakes um that's a big question um
wait I I know where he's going huge
yeah wait how does God wait hold on I'm
no
theologist how does God make
mistakes that well uh theoretically he
doesn't but I think that's where Jesse
is going with this is well just say no
that's the easy dub right because if you
know but like how does God make mistakes
doesn't that undermine the whole the
whole ass
thing like if he makes mistakes that
he's no better than us right well just
I have a feeling Jesse's trying
to set up a a a Mind Trap I know but if
he gave the easy answer which is no
right the TR would be conversation over
right yeah yeah it's interesting you're
talking about everything that is that is
involved at the not only at the bottom
of this universe but whatever other what
other uh whatever other inner universes
exist so uh I would say that
um it's got to be I don't think actually
that force that we call God wait this
guy this guy's a real this Force we call
God this guy's a priest it's talking
like a
damn wait yeah Ethan you didn't get that
yeah that's why Jesse is so mind blown I
know but he's a priest that's like
whatever this entity God is called he
doesn't sound like a he's Progressive
right well that doesn't even sound like
Christianity he's doing like d like uh
what whatever I'm not sure uh I think
it's nice I'm not sure he's definitely
Progressive I mean what's his name does
it say uh priest confesses to Jesse I'm
gay that's the name of the video great
uh What uh Tom Cary of sacred resistance
La sacred resist I'm going to look up
what denomination they are probably like
Lutheran or something uh sa resistance
so actually also I believe that things
un in a moment for us and that so that
you know time itself is an illusion I
mean not you know that that that so um
who is this guy the power of the I
didn't know Christians talked like that
I'm ready to I've tried to explain to
you it's a it's a big religion there's
lots of different strains you know
they're not all the psychos but
no I know but they all believe like
Jesus that's the whole point is God sure
I in Sweden literally what Christianity
is this is very like Swedish VI because
in Sweden they even say I don't know if
Jesus existed some priests like is it is
it just a story it's like they they they
really are keep everything ambiguous so
I guess I just don't understand even
fitting that kind of philosophy in the
framework of Christianity right well I I
would I I will admit that uh the more uh
fundamentalist or even just Mainline
Christians probably would say oh if you
think that then you're not a real
Christian or whatever you know what I
mean but yeah I mean so what's his
denomination uh I was trying to figure
that out uh I do see when I search for
sacred resistance La an Episcopal dicese
came up but um so but I I don't know if
that is his uh what do Episcopal do
isn't that when you eat
fish you thinking of pescatarian oh
okay uh believe it the Episcopal is a
branch off of Anglican which is the
Church of England it's I'm far from the
right person all right well so there it
is he's we love it we love it and uh
versus fan favorite I'm sure nobody's
gon to say no to to the scha looma see
it can you switch so I can see it oh or
do I need the minim I got a soft one
this is the fried chicken one I got the
circle one hard taco was this your first
time trying Taco Bell oh it wasn't the
first time it was the first time of you
getting it after you moved here right
right that's probably okay so this was a
big moment yeah another soft one and
where's my sha Loompa I told you I think
that they forgot one they forgot my sha
looma bro what the hell so sorry was
like one thing missing see they always
something that's why I ordered a lot I'm
still I I ordered with them with that in
mind that they might lose one something
a't going to W yes so this why did it
have to be the cha Loompa though yeah
that's tragic like they knew they're
teasing me bro teas you know I ordered
Italian food over the weekend and I got
a pizza they forgot the pizza what the
they just brought a bag I was like
the no way you're M you forgot the
Pizza it's a big ass box where's
my
Shala uh it was the kids food too it was
a night you're serious they
forgot yeah that's crazy they forgot the
pizza oh my God
um so there it is Jesse Lee Peterson's
gay rant versus L's schuma Loompa
disaster you all look gay all right I
will say about I love the love one these
Jesse Lee Peterson's ones are like
they're so good he's so funny there's
like like there's more in the clip like
he's got a line about keeping earth
clean and zebras go ahead and play your
favorites to keep the earth clean and do
what zebras do do what zebras do it it's
just like and he's got like this Lin but
being gay and being black is different
and like
Les's amazing Les like this is like some
Fred Norris level like it's so good
I the problem with Jesse is that we
haven't really
dedicated significant time to
understanding and talking about him that
I don't think the audience is fully
caught up on the Jesse Lee Peterson uh
character me come up a lot over the
years but you're right but we haven't
done a true Deep dive into him at any
point I sneak him in like especially the
uh amazing mind blowing well anyway
Jesse Lee Peterson it doesn't even
matter CU you're getting blown out by
love schuma Loompa 69% completely 31%
mindblowing I'm glad we didn't do the
Jenna thing or whatever that is I don't
even know what that is wait why are
people saying
rigged rigged how you got 10,000 votes
70% love there's no rigged here no
that's that's that's a clear winner give
break I support genocide okayo genocide
okay n no that one we didn't enter not
included okay very good congratulations
love that's exciting for you how do you
feel do you feel oh no I feel honored of
course yeah thank you everyone thank you
everyone Jesse is catching up but no way
he's going to be able to close that Gap
so have I I don't know if have I ever
been up for a sound bite here's one of
me I don't know if I've ever been
nominated uh hm M but anyway it's me the
it's said the in unintelligible scream
still don't know what you're saying from
the from the the live uh members drive
versus Enrique and golly I love Enrique
so I don't think I've got much a shot
here with this one but here it
is right now I'm
back wait what happened from right now
I'm
back what it's
it you know what I'm saying you sound
like a Cy Master oh Ela knew that's the
crazy part she knew what I was saying
it's that's nuts that she knew we we
speak our our children goat like Bruce
goes exactly he doesn't say Daddy he
says Day Day a it's like one word d d d
so I say sit
it doesn't make any sense yeah I
still don't get it I still don't get it
your explanation makes no sense I think
I don't know why it came up but I was
very
drunk uh versus a really terrific one I
love the Enrique stuff man it is so oh
yes very late
[Music]
Comer the Rhythm
divide Lo in the music your heart will
be my all I
need in your
eyes you be
my have this feeling forever to live
this moment
together matters just you and the
night sing you you know to
stop it all you are my heart you are my
soul and he is currently on tour by the
way with Pitbull and Ricky Martin oh my
God it's shocking how bad it is it's
crazy so cool like the worst karaoke
you've ever heard one one small uh
amendment I forgot that we bundled in
this one hello every do you think he's a
pathological liar
whoa the one where it goes hey everyone
welcome back to on purpose the number
one Health podcast in the world thanks
to each and why do you need to like why
do you feel the need to like aren't you
supposed to be humble like why you out
here flexing like oh I'm number one in
the world like aren't you supposed to be
a who said who said he has to be humble
who said with eyes like that let him let
him cook dude dude I'm just saying he's
a phon
baloney he's the realest I agree the
real or the real love you J rainy day
out here in Los Angeles thanks for
thanks for that guys you should have
known I was going to lose when that
happened I mean you did I did yeah I
said I
said J shett didn't say why did they
include that it's mindblowing it's mind
J shy should have said it was raining he
didn't right my you gave
us an atmosphere when you build your
podcast J shed just leaves it he just
say he goes oh I'm the best yeah hey
guys welcome I'm the best mhm you say
the sky is blue I'm like here let's give
some information that's relevant to all
your lives that could you know enrich
you with knowledge and power yes um so
let's throw it up uh it's up it's it
it's me versus
Enrique I'm voting for Enrique
personally o we got a close one on our
hands here it looks like there's no way
mine is better I mean rainy day in Los
Angeles was pretty iconic that's true
that one was F and Enrique Enrique is a
late entry it was just within the last
few weeks that we discovered play the
other ones then Zach maybe that'll
change the vote I only pulled uh that
one from the recent touring that's the
one I play though the one that we
watched is the one that he has in his
Sound Bank yeah uh I can find the uh the
other one okay so no so never mind no no
no no that's not but right that one that
is the sound bite is the one we we watch
so well I'm got to be I'm surprised that
y'all or cuz I just thought the Enrique
one is so funny but oh people are
suggesting that that sound bite of you
that we don't understand is you saying
it's shed like it's shett no you're
giving him props no I clearly said I'm
it's I explained it in the clip we watch
it's not sh you did not explain it
clearly I said I I combined it's it it's
it it's it yeah but why like cuz Bruce
does it why I brought it up I have no
idea it was not relevant to the
okay all right well that's that's me so
sorry Enrique wow toppling Enrique no
the uh sit and rainy day
okay whatever you guys think and yeah
rainy day in Los Angeles we we got a lot
of play out of that it's true that's
true well so that was round eight so we
are
halfway through let's take a look at our
left side bracket then yeah let's see
what we got so to recap the winners here
it's going to be exciting the next round
we had round one was won by my boy
tipster followed by a uh preach of ABA
and preach uh talking about eggshells
and bracket huge bracket uh down here
fan of the show Gizzy the Gizzy king or
Gizzy Master gzy bot Gizzy bot gzy bot
neither uh took round three round four
uh our president your president you know
him love him Donald trumped me uh with
his audio package uh followed by the
death nail sound of Mitch mcconell
seeing the Grim
Reaper and then we have in round seven
Boogie taking it over that loser idiot
dumbass
Crowder close
though uh sorry that was round six round
seven was Love's uh schal Loa taking it
over uh brother that's mind blowing and
finally Ethan Ed out surpr icon Enrique
a glacius with uh it's a rainy day in
Los Angeles I'm sure surprised by that
so there you go we have our first it's a
rainy day out here well there's some
really exciting brackets to look forward
to there but now we're switching to the
right side and we have a whole fresh new
column to work through like I told you
guys this is a serious Endeavor this is
not something to be taken lightly
absolutely not in fact I'm going to run
to the bathroom really fast sure but uh
the next one here we've got the good
doctor sound package which he he had a
big
year and um I said no
pickles wait who's he
against sorry what's that is he against
Michaela Michaela yeah oh okay okay I
couldn't tell oh that's makeup back
yeah all right I'll be right back I'm
just going to run to the all right
sounds good uh I had a gripad donos
coming in so let me pull
up my little thing here I guess let me
start from the back get the earlier ones
$20 uh from Hao
Hao uh would love to hear what y'all
have to say about Shawn Mendes and Miley
Cyrus apparently joining a cult sent a
message on Discord to Olivia about it on
Sunday uh Olivia stepped away I think
our sandwiches are here uh that's the
first time hearing about it um yeah pop
stars and Cults kind of like kind of in
right now seems like a lot of them do
you know about this Miley joining a cult
theoretically or something is that true
I don't know if it's true I'm uh we had
a don't know that was uh Shawn Mendes
and Miley Cyrus apparently joining a
cult that's true that'd be crazy
apparently this person sent you a
message on Discord so if you want to
look through your DMs you might have
some info there wait yeah we'll look
into it uh Ben
beia sorry if I'm mispronouncing that uh
Mayo Clinic for Sam oh because she cut
herself that's funny clever like it good
job good one Ben ma for uh Aaron
Montes uh let's see uh big fan of the
show just a quick follow up on yesterday
most migrant arrivals at the border are
Asylum Seekers yes that's true uh that's
a legal form of immigration agreed
conservatives use illegal not knowing
that to scare others uh well we can't
just put that on conservatives anymore
CU I just was reading about how Joe
Biden is uh making a border Crackdown
part of his deal with the the GE PE so
shout out shout out to the Democrats uh
Jess lay uh member for2 years $20 I'm
pregnant with my third baby
congratulations been pregnant with Ela
each pregnancy oh that's cool and also
have two boys can't wait to find out the
gender this time boy mom is my destiny
too I think love you all so much uh well
if you're pulling for a girl hope for
that but uh if you get three boys that's
great too congrats Jess uh it's ducky yo
that's a perfect
name I'm sorry I don't know what that's
referring to at all the dog's name is
Ducky oh for ducky yeah oh cuz their
name is it's ducky oh good catch and
they donate 50 bucks so thank you it's
ducky that's a very generous of you dude
uh yeah Ducky's really cute actually you
guys remember I wanted to name my son
ducky but everyone hated that I think
it's a great name for for a boy I love
that isn't that like in tequilla Mocking
Bird that's the kid's name or Dill maybe
it's Dill I don't remember ducky ducky
is just such a cute little name the
daughter you know you know where I got
the idea um it's from Kendrick lar song
his I guess his Maiden last name is
Duckworth his dad's name and he says in
his song they used to call him ducky and
I was like that's such a awesome name I
love that lucky ducky I never heard of
it before but okay the dog gets it the
dog gets it whenever you give ducky a
treat you can call him lucky
ducky Kobe Brian's middle name was Bean
because his dad's nickname was Joey
Bean his middle name was Bean yeah his
Kobe Bean Bryant what is that real I
never knew that we and he's named after
the beef too
huh yo moli culin legally changed his
name to Molly Molly kulen kulen he like
made it a Twitter thing people got to
choose he didn't have to do that I know
he did it for us he's pretty great I
agree it's been uh become a friend of
the uh the red letter media guys I don't
know if any of you guys ever watch those
guys I do yeah I enjoy them he pops in
as a as a third mic on their uh on their
show I wonder if we can out do you think
we could get moli Cen Cen I think so out
can we get the RM guys with them too red
letter media I mean that'd be cool but
do they ever leave do they ever leave
Minnesota or Wisconsin I don't know if
he'll agree with your uh your takes on
MJ he might see that he might see uh the
clip on MJ is an MJ Defender is he an MJ
supporter yeah he is that' be
interesting I'm going put to hearing him
okay well maybe we'll line that up next
year sometime I I'm open I'm open baby
he was there so he knows
yeah damn that's a good sandwich so good
um we have the same one right you got
that Beretta no I got see I didn't get
the Beretta cuz it has the the nasty
slimy I got the Baretta I have the same
one but I got the
uh
capry CPR so
good um do you want me to keep going on
these so you can um Chow real quick um
are you ready to jump back into it um I
got a lot go ahead yeah go ahead let's
catch up and Dan those were all positive
can we get some like terminal illnesses
or some more depress sure yeah um
yeah um let's see this person they
donated $500 and said my entire family
was killed in a building fire yesterday
sorry to hear it but thanks for the
Dono that's not a real one that's what
I'm talking about um let's
see uh let's see what else we got my cat
stormmy recently celebrated her 20th
birthday can I get a hell yeah from the
crew yeah hell yeah you can 20 is way up
there for cat that's amazing hell yeah
hell
yeah congrats Maggie and congrats to
stormy as well for making it 20 whole
years
um
Rachel uh donate 10 bucks and said
completely relate to Dan I have no time
for excitement finals for my master
program this week and then I fly out on
Saturday oh you're flying to the
show oh so you're doing finals and then
straight to the H3 podcast live show
well we'll see you there good luck good
luck on the
finals uh $20 from Leora uh watch new
Undead
mummy does anybody know what that is
referring to that's the animator stop
motion yeah it's what Danel Clansman
stop motion account that we've shown on
the show oh okay we check that out later
um remind me uh Dr bluntman 420 let's
go
dude pH for the gift D love that uh I
did the same thing to my finger at Jimmy
John's and got the tip in the
lettuce dude I nasty I worked at a deli
uh in high school for a little while and
I was so scared of the uh meat
slicer thing like anytime I didn't I was
mostly just worked in the back but
anytime I had to use it I was like so
paranoid that I was going to slice
something
off um o k donated $5 and said Gizzy
gang Gizzy gang your boy uh your boy won
his first round so congrats to you thank
you Stephen A for the gifted oh and
Lauren too wow thank you guys of gifted
come coming in uh $20 from new sling
release my friend after pie from Shadow
band prison please they're huge fans and
feel sad and confused by the ban well
they probably deserved it I don't know
what to tell you can you look up can you
look into it and see why there I can no
I can't see why I there's no
like twitch has like a whole like log
feature where you can see everything
like a user sent or whatever YouTube has
nothing of the sort uh so so it would be
super useful YouTube I mean twitch has
had that for years too it would be good
content I know the ban appeals that
would be good um I can try and look into
it frankly uh you can't even find people
by their names to unban them like the
fact that you said their name is after
pie that that does nothing for me you
need the um Channel URL which is so
stupid that's the only way to uh
manually unban somebody so um I don't
know if you want to uh send their uh
their Channel URL to one of the mods or
something I can I can do it I mean yeah
I guess I'll ban them whatever it's
probably not that serious listen wait if
you're being obnoxious in the chat we
ban you that's that's it so just don't
be obnoxious and you're you're good um
Josie
donated specifically if you're being
annoying when there's a guest on that's
kind of like an easy way to get basy
know easy ban right there we just don't
want our guests to be like constantly
harassed mhm just get Juiced it's not a
good look
no I'm just going to finish this half
and I'm going put the rest in the
braid like one more
bite I have
not chewed or talked into the mic with
food in my
mouth let you
know oh I see n sling they they replied
she said she barely
chats damn they must have been they must
have been really annoying then damn must
have left a
doozy left some a real turd of a comment
there no uh yeah new if you want to um
yeah again the channel URL that's the
only way for me to uh find somebody so
um you know if you want to send that to
me on Discord or something I'll I'll
take a look uh let's see
um Josie donated $10 said my boyfriend
Eric got a promotion he watches every
episode and might poop himself if he
gets a shout out he works so hard I'm so
proud H3 brought us together we love you
guys family that's very nice shout out
Eric congrats on the promotion love you
guys all right you good can you do me a
favor just fridge that that was so good
oh my god dude yeah this place this
place rocks can we say the name now that
we we've already ordered give him a
plug it's fine right
yeah why not uh I don't think they need
business because I'm assuming they're
super popular but it's called
just bread All About The Bread close all
about the bread it's called it's all
about bread you know what I'll say the
bread today was really a lot better than
I remember the bread was crazy today
yeah he was trying to talk the
bread at All About The
Bread I wasn't talking I was just
saying it's not that good to justify a
name like
that but today the bread was actually
really really good so maybe it is all
about the bread it's a
juicer all right thank you everybody for
standing back and standing by let's move
on to the uh fabled second right side
bracket we have so much work to do and
so little time my friends let us
continue the good
doctor vers Michaela makeup bag K
Kardashian turning violet Violet so
let's begin here
I am a
surgeon I am a
surgeon I am I am a surgeon I am a
surgeon Dr H I am the surgeon watch
surge I adore
that and
he he does not for the
record have I assuming the doctor has
autism yeah yeah he's autistic uh the
actor does not know he does not have
autism yeah no I remember when we were
talking about this there was a lot of
discourse cuz this clip went viral and
uh there were a lot of people that were
not thrilled with that show's uh
depiction it seems kind of silly the
whole premise is silly like he's on one
hand this super high level surgeon but
also like emotionally
completely uh immature I don't I don't
know I mean
I don't
know no I don't know anything about
autism though to be fair
so uh here's another one from the the
good
surgeon no the good doctor whatever the
no no what's the matter no no no
what are you seeing I can't can't do
this what can you do no don't no no
no no no Dr Murphy no Dr Murphy okay you
if you're a surgeon and you act like
that you take off you should lose your
job you should not ever work yeah no
like I'm sorry you're not you're not up
to the task dude the way they portray
him is like I do not want him as a
doctor ever like this he's a Mania you
can't do that mid
surgery Murphy no he took off his like
mask no I'm sure like in the context of
the episode there was like a reason for
that but yeah I mean that feels like
that's that's
crossing that's huge line right there
right we're we're not ready for the
doctor role yeah but anyway here's a
recent uh entry making its rounds which
I really enjoyed uh I said no
pickles
true some people said no pickles pardon
me he's on a date it's okay they can
just take that I said no pickles oh I am
so sorry I said no
pickles the
[Laughter]
slowmo no pickles my friends I said no
pickles so that's the good doctor we've
had a good time with him but okay so how
do we feel oopsy doopsy but up next is
really a strong Contender Michaela
makeup bag Barbie Kim kardashi she's
strong we had that was just a good good
at this makeup bag
I I am so this is going to be my
I believe is she she watches the show
right I recall yeah I think she told us
at the at the oh yeah we met her at this
this filter is supposed right we met her
at the bad place the award show that
shall not be named so okay well that
that makes me like her even
more she's got what does she have like a
missile on her
nose it's Contour I mean it's just a
filter it's not actually to make you
look like babby is this going to make me
look like babby absolutely not but let's
do it anyways again we got got babby we
got makeup
bag and the most famous One Kim
Kardashian had this
AB stunning sexy look at the Met Gala
and you can read yeah Kim Kardashian so
that is our friend Michaela verse no
pickles the good doctor
uh interesting bracket I said no pickles
I think probably
iich got easy dub yeah I think
Michaela's got it but we'll see and and
we love the good doctor we we appreciate
all the good work he
does but I think Michaela ran away with
it this year babby well poll is up and
you are right that she has a strong lead
here although not not I mean it's
definitely she's going to win yeah but
59 me look like babby 41 41% of the good
doctor I mean you know okay we can wrap
it up congratulations Michaela sorry
about that good
doctor keep writing crazy episodes and
maybe next year you'll you'll have a
better can't can't do this oh man the
next one is Rich Lux who has had such a
phenomenal year his um his beef with Dan
has been a focal point of of locks of
tension between between us a here is him
in his video titled by the way Ethan
Klein won't fire Dan from h3h3
productions for poor work behavior and
other stuff too drama he's he really
came for you Dan I know it's up I
thought I'm still big mad about it too
and I'll tell you I thought I was like
maybe I do need to fire dad Rich Lu
makes a good point
here
Dan is jealous of me and let me tell you
the drama with Dan great drop this was
last so there's that one and then
there's also incidentally uh the
complete opposite thing I
see Adam McIntyre said talking about
this drama let me play the clip remember
that what happened I think it was during
the ace Fest Fallout right we were
talking K won't stop what the are
you what did I do Adam Ethan Klein won't
stop
what D what did I do oh was this all
over the oh my
God hold on well you were going to type
something in me Dan I saw me oh no oh
you were cool I thought you were eating
a sandwich Oh I thought you okay I
thought you were telling me to I nay on
the no I don't give a yeah okay
they were going is this what they're
going on and on about Dan this insane
accusation against Dan doing I don't
think it was that so what did I do Adam
I don't know Ethan won't stop making
great content sorry
bro sorry that I keep your ass
entertained three days a
week deeply apologetic I don't think I I
think you may have be reading into this
a little too much um maybe it's possible
right we were talking about how he got
kicked out of the
event oh yeah so so this was the um I
guess what I said was offensive was the
the bottom the bottom
stuff oh was it that
that's I guess he he did a whole uh
presentation on me being homophobic I
guess like this
year uh seems like it or was the bottom
thing this year no this was that was
long this was Fallout we had like talked
about it on the show I'm pretty sure so
he brought it back up no we brought it
back up oh we did yeah and then he was
watching it and then Rich was watching
him watch it well anyway I do apologize
for that one I
feel I feel I've come a long way I've
learned quite a bit from uh from all my
faux Paws I've made over the
years I would agree apparently I
wouldn't
stop that's the title that's the title
of his video anyway go ahead Rich talk
about it but when um it was sent in chat
Dan said he said it on the show when it
happened he was like I just I just
banned him I Remember You Banned him but
and
Dan so good I can't stand
Dan
Dan blocked me for my favorite show H3
H3
Dan is jealous of me and let me tell you
the drama with Dan oh wait this is the
same spot so the other one is just Dan
is Queen but that didn't bring me to the
Dan as Queen oh uh bad you
Dan is the
Queen the queen so that's the Dan is the
queen yeah love Dan so that's rich Lux
entry up against quite a a wild card
here the chiropractor uh screams of
[Laughter]
Despair this was a recent
entry that's
real this is genuine like torment I mean
every time I play this Dan loses I it's
gen these are some of my favorite sound
buys ever like dude I that man is truly
truly suffering I just can't believe how
much it sounds like a stock sound effect
from the 1940s it sounds like a Tom and
Jerry cartoon it's like perfect yeah I
mean my heart goes out to him the
chiropractor is like you got scoliosis
all right I'm going to fold you like a
beach chair
like that is the sound that is the sound
that uh Tom makes when Jerry chops his
tail off or something you know what
I poor guy genuinely wow that was better
so we've got chiropractor death
rattles versus Rich Lux can't stand Dan
Dan is the queen interesting bracket
here let's see I mean people love the
rich ones I predict the win he's a fan
of the show which I love I can't stand
he's a good sport he's a great guy Dan
block me and I love the feud truly I do
I love the feud Dan ruined my whole
Disney
trip all right well I'm throwing up the
poll round 10 there's lots of um Cairo
haters they don't they say it's too much
it's too much there's lots of people
like I can't watch it you got to chill
on the chiropractor stuff so I don't
know if that's factor
[Music]
in
but do we have no pain larain drops no I
never use those this
year uh so but anyway Rich Lux is
winning 64% I can't stand Dan and well
you are alone in that we all love Dan so
love Dan easy dub for Rich easy
dub congrats Rich I'm excited for to see
what you can pull off this year up next
we've got Kid Rock Grandpa's feeling a
little frisky today which I love love
love and of course Joe Biden's Infamous
Mayo for
Sam let's take a listen and a
gander here is uh Kid Rock who I should
remind you has been spotted drinking Bud
Light since this video came out so this
was of course over Dylan mulany oh I
just saw an update that the
conservatives are back on board with um
with Bud Light oh they're back all was
forgiv what did Bud Light do I don't
know I think they I think they paid them
I was say dud did they like uh Deport a
bunch of people no Dana White was doing
like an interview with Tucker Carlson or
something and he's going on and on about
how you're you're not a real American if
you don't drink Bud Light and blah blah
blah like and I think Kid Rock even did
some endorsement I swear let me look it
up right now all this you
literally bust out a
rifle to Sho yeah here it is 9 hours ago
Kid Rock says he's done boycotting Bud
Light oh he was done back in he was done
that day dude we spotted you long time
ago what a dumbass so's changing his
tune on budlight he was one of the first
people to declare the boycott Rock told
Tucker Carlson on his X show that
budlight deserved a black eye and they
got it so now I do I want to hold their
head underwater and drown them because
they made a mistake no got the message
yeah don't worry they're selling beer
with or without you yeah um wow what a
worthless virtue signal that you hate
trans people that was really awesome
dude anyway here it
is grandpa is feeling a little frisky
today uh-oh let me uh say something to
all you and be as clear it's usually
something you'd hear Chris Hansen a
transcript Chris
Hansen and concise as possible go ahead
Chris don't you take a sheet right over
there yeah we showed them dumb
we showed them for working with a small
trans Creator on like a tiny uh campaign
that nobody knew about what a single can
a single can with her face on it was
sent to
her that's it oh was just one can one
can oh so they weren even no no she just
posted with it no it was just a social
media okay so they paid her it was a
paid advert I think they probably didn't
even pay her they probably just sent it
to her and she showed it cuz it was cool
they sent I think they did it for a
bunch of influencers oh my God that's
that is really that's even CRA no it is
the
dumbest dumbest Scandal you could
possibly
imagine you sure they weren't paying her
I don't believe I'm double cheing right
now but that's
nuts that's nuts yeah I think it's just
one of those things that they they sent
them to a bunch of popular influencers
to yeah I mean it's viral marketing kind
of you know I thought they were at
least like partnered up like financially
but just send I think I could I'm not a
th% sure on that but I'm I'm pretty
certain no well we'll we'll fact Che
that but in the meantime thank you Kid
Rock for that really meaningful uh uh
protest and I'm and I'm so sorry to hear
that you're back on Bud Light uh they
got you man I wonder if Jeremy has made
a uh video dlan M this week cuz as like
I haven't checked on his channel in a
while but he was still juicing the Bud
Light thing months later okay well he
posts like five videos a day uh oh right
he's he's desperate for Content oh
Jeremy and keemstar having a tiff which
kind of funny oh no he's he's okay he's
railing against Dave Ruben and Shane
Dawson uh
adopting uh babies or they had surrogate
mothers I think or I don't know yeah
yeah they s gave birth to twins and so
um quering says no no
no this disgusting Trend Dave Rubin and
Shane Dawson are promoting buying babies
I'm buying
babies keemstar came at him though woke
star you are 40 years old and two gay
guys had a kid before you
loser kind of
awesome rare Keem dub um here's a a
video on the cording channel from seven
days ago Dylan malany humiliated Jesus
Christ man look at the tears it's like
hell man that does numbers too
23 people love it people click for that
that's sad that is
sad to be fair I don't think keemstar
has a
biological child either I am seeing
although he's not I don't think I
thought I'm seeing that she was paid his
daughter the can was never sold is
oh brentley's his daughter no no he's
not dating his daughter I know that
that's confusing but so so I'm saying he
doesn't have a biological
child um I think he may also have that
uh she may be one of brantley's friends
or something I'm not entirely certain on
how that Dynamic works but that could be
how they met sorry AB go ahead sorry I
was just saying that Dylan was paid but
like Dan said it was just one can it was
not sold okay a sponsored post got it
all right uh where were we we were
talking about
uh uh Kid Rock vers male for Sam let's
here
Joe people of
mayo this is a moment to recommit our
hearts our minds our ENT souls to the
march of progress to lay the foundations
Brick by Brick by Brick for a better
future for our kids and our grandkids
man better future man one of Greater
Liberty opportunity and
dignity just like our an ancestors did
for us
yes I've never been more optimistic and
I've been doing this a long time I've
never been more optimistic about what we
can achieve if we stick together and
stick to our values do you think that's
true that he's never been more
optimistic I don't know if it's just
like always a thing where you feel at
the time like it's this is worse than
it's ever been type of thing like I
don't know if people always feel that I
have a hard time believing that he
actually believes that this he's never
been more optimistic in the future I
mean maybe he feels that way I mean he's
probably stoked he got to be president
right exactly right that's good for him
he stoked on that
possibilities and United by history
where's male for Sam Heritage and hope
it's coming up and maybe most of all by
courage nothing is beyond our
reach every time I walked out of my
grandfather Fan's home in Scranton
Pennsylvania y Joey keep the faith
then I'd hear someone from the house
yell no Joey spread
[Music]
it
right may God
protect all those who serve the cause of
peace dude this is Joe Biden propaganda
why is this URL so far back which one of
you the
stff one more
thing mail for
Sam mail for Sam that makes no sense
what did he mean by that Mayo for Sam
it's um Mayo is a town and uh it's a
it's a soccer reference I'm sorry
football May for Sam better watch so he
did say mayale for Sam yeah yeah it's a
reference to the Sam Maguire cup that
Mayo last won in 1951 when a local
priest was said to have put a curse on
the team for a lack of respect when
their bus passed a funeral on their way
home to the final in Dublin whoa
okay that's a very Irish Story the
audience loved it you could tell but
okay moving or well let's let's throw it
to the people we've got Kid Rock
Grandpa's feeling
frisky Joe Biden our very own president
uh uh Mayo for for
Sam all right going up right
now grandpa is feeling a little frisky
today you know
I I think the mail for Sam one is just a
little
more personal mhm but the the the Kid
Rock one is also very versatile and very
funny you it's so it's you can use it in
really up ways feeling a little
frisky today but the people are
definitely speaking up for male for Sam
they they voed their opinion loud and
clear with 4,000 quotes that's
76% Joe Biden mayil for Sam so that's
easy so we can lock that up right now
sorry about that Kid
Rock
sorry
buddy up next we've got Pearl Davis oh
boy remember her unfortunately uh we've
got a few of hers just her going mhm mhm
or and also can we talk about the Jews
song oh Jesus right versus excc AAR and
oh and his rumbling rambling which
is similar to
fidus but
let's take a listen here go ahead
Pearl
um yeah just I think it's a bit
disingenuous okay bro this has 2.6
million views holy that's awesome
wait really yeah I one got that high up
dude that's
crazy that's great that was a lark
interview I I got to tell you um no
spoilers but you know I guess this isn't
really a spoiler uh cam is working on
his uh end of the year wrap-up video um
that we always do at the end of the year
and some of these clips went in there
and I hadn't gone back and watched any
of this since it happened and this might
be the most cringe thing that we've ever
done on the show it's like borderline
unwatchable to me like this interview
it's so uncomfortable it was
like painful painful watching this I
love that it's so brutal the the debates
were were really a highlight of the Year
for me i' love to keep doing more next
year like really I want to get get them
keep them coming you know yeah we have
some of them we're trying to get in
touch with right
now great and let's keep a list going I
you know if you guys have any ideas for
people debate too send them in Discord
because I want I do want to start
reaching out and get more people on the
show um but anyway that's
Pearl wait did I even say somebody said
um the Pearl interview was how they got
into the Pod that was the first thing
they
that's incredible yeah all the debates
has done so well on social media some of
the best performing content we've posted
so I'm surprised that's good stuff that
was also during the time when we were
actually gaining subs for a minute well
Bri that's true that that's that's
actually that's very meaningful if we're
getting Subs then I think we got to we
got to hit the iron while it's hot even
though they've lost relevancy that's why
I'll always advocate for fresh and Fit I
think that'd be a good
discussion I was watching watching one
of their shows the other day and it's
insane they start by like a doctor's
office he has a a clipboard and he ask
every girl in the room myON asks how old
are you are you on birth control are
your parents divorced oh my God it's
like the stupidest misogynistic
questions ever I I couldn't believe what
I was watching I think that I agree I
think it could be there's I'll have to
do so much preparation for that cuz like
their lore is deep and Myon is
not he's not like a total
uh he can argue yeah he he can argue but
that's fine I mean Olie was was a pretty
yeah out of all the ones this year Olli
was definitely the person that like
could actually hold a conversation
without just collapsing like the rest
and my room would probably be similar to
that yeah yeah um but I I I would be
open to reaching out actually maybe we
should do that I would even debate them
two verse one I'd love to talk to Coco I
mostly want to talk to coconuts Coco
frankly Coco it's a I call them Coco my
it's just shortened to Coco now but
anyway Pearl we love
you yeah reach out let's write that
thank you yeah just I think it's a bit
disingenuous
okay why why is it disingenuous I'm I'm
analyzing your viability by your own
metrics you why is it brushed forward
Day to other women and men why is that
disingenuous so sweaty I don't you're in
business
mode that right there
so close to okay Ethan so close oh
that's true we did miss out on that from
her so that was a good Pearl moment we
had and shout out to
her uh talk about the Jews song was
something that came up after my
conversation with her I had not enjoyed
this before but she ENC she
um she is very adamant she wants us all
to know this is not anti-semitic she
says it's just a
joke
why why can't we talk about
[Music]
them without getting kicked off of you
to now I'm not saying Hitler was a good
guy jeez that is a crazy lyric but I
kind of want to
know why
why now there's all these conspiracy
theories this is maybe and the more they
talk the craziest thing anyone's ever
uploaded I mean this is nuts no
think maybe they're
right God remember when she got owned by
pi Morgan of all people on this wow yeah
which like just says it all when Pierce
Morgan is dunking on your ass I you know
I gota I feel I've been watching a lot
of Pierce Morgan his his Channel's been
quite good lately I'm not even listen
he's he interviews a really good
diversity of people he's had tons of pro
Palestinian people on and he gives them
yeah to his credit he has been fairly
good on that and um he gives them tons
of space and he's like really not rude
to them either he's juicing that
conflict like no other he's benefiting
the most out of that every single day
true here Morgan always comes out on top
you're not wrong but the content is is
good oh yeah no I there's there's a one
interview with the one sha and the one
um Rabbi which is just insane oh God no
one can get a word in and dud that Rabbi
is that guy is nuts yeah I didn't see
this one both them it's intense
huh the one chank with the rabbi you
said yeah M dude that one is like
intensely insane chank has like a
meltdown but this Rabbi is like so mean
but anyway I I anyway whatever so moving
on I'm sorry no I'm talking about the
one with uh the rabbi and the Muhammad
uh I forget his name but he he's he's uh
not the one Jank I I watched some of
that one too but was it the same Rabbi
uh cuz that guy's wild anyway whatever
let's move on so we got M and talk about
the Jews M thank you Pearl and we have
xqc making an entry here let's give this
one a
try a carrot let's give this one a TR
class and he's we've decided he's he's
serious about that yes he thought he
pulled a carrot
out
interesting I mean that's kind of a Vibe
for w why
not so go ahead and play there's another
excc entri Z with build constructive but
just Pi T across that's just mean says
seen a
very
[Music]
good so we we've got uh XC verse Pearl
two and two people have debated
actually uh this year right so right I
forgot the xcc one I I love the xqc the
Pearl one is very um very soft and you
can kind of throw it in spots yeah I
love when you just have her go the
mhm okay so let's throw it up we got
Pearl and we got round 12 Pearl versus
xqc the Battle of the great minds of of
the internet the carrot vers the uh the
stick and the
mud xqc is destroying her
initially I think people just really
hate Pearl they can't even vote for her
in this capacity right and I don't blame
you they they're like I don't want to
see or hear from her anymore right so
I'm voting for
xqc yeah we're locking that up is that
anything wrong with stre had to build
constructive but just to WIP with R
that's just mean that is just mean
whatever you said sorry about that or
happy for you whatever that's just mean
yeah so anyway congrats xqc pearl easy
another L for Pearl this year this she
can't stop taking the
L's Dolly llama was that this year huh
suck my tongue that was a crazy one that
one was
[Music]
crazy and then keemstar the rim shot
sound effect which we've
appropriated every show since uh
we discovered it it's quite good yeah I
love that we just ripped it cuz
I was laughing about how dumb it is and
then we just ripped that
dude and now it's
great uh the boy's face is blurred okay
so I'm not even going to show it but you
can hear oh wait you don't have us
reacting to
it no it's just the the footage of
it
[Music]
he's yeah just staring at him quiet very
awkwardly and Su my
Tong e e oh they do it oh my God you're
such a wow wow wow that one's wild wild
wild that makes that is really suck my
tongue you know what China you got the
green light take that non stop
that's take it
all just kidding I stand with tobat
forever hands in the Fists in the air
baby freedom for
everyone uh so we got uh Dolly llama
vers keemstar thank you Zach you played
it one more
time and we also have brandley making an
entry kids aren't skating and causing a
lawsuit you are a loser well that's your
job you're a fun sucker that is the job
if you had a skateboard and your car is
on the other I remember this brenley had
a uh Moment of clarity when talking
about
AB but um anyway we got Dolly llama
versus keemstar two great spiritual
leaders wait did you play that the
actual keemstar room show yeah did I
miss that yeah no I played on the
soundboard oh we didn't play the clip of
it oh here I'll play the far
away why not it'll be fun and if I see a
car I'm not a dumbass I'm going see the
car's there and I'mma stop Brantley or
get out the way you have a mental
disability known as gen
[Music]
Z and let me you are not allowed to push
the button Brantley only I can push the
button here dude also what the was
that that is the greatest part about
this whole thing is that sound bad that
sound is that like his Rim sha yes I
think seems to just play that whenever
he thinks he really he really got one
over sometimes you got to support
yourself you know i' I'm I love that I
love that so much so he's doing his own
Rim shots it's it's it's quite good
because we're now using it unironically
to the point where I don't even think
anyone even thinks about the origin of
it we've just completely culturally
appropriated keemstar and we found out a
fan sent us a message that it's like a
stock stock sound effect in whatever
mixer he's using awesome he can't say
so I'm glad to have taken that y
it's ours
now so anyway um we've got KY
dreamy Rim shot KY so dreamy vers D Lama
which I forget what what round was
this I'll say this the DOL llama one is
really bad vibes so it's vile yeah I'm
not sure that a lot of people are going
to be running to vote for that
one um was this I think this this is
round 13 let me just verify real quick
we have the tongue sucker versus the
phone sucker yeah it's 13 round 13 okay
uh pulls up all right everybody we've
got the tongue suck and suck versus the
funck fun suck what you said AB I heard
you hey
hey we're making
progress I kind of heard you I had to
infer a lot I know I think you had you
once you said it you're like oh that's
what it
was um this is this is truly a
devastating blowout for the dolly llama
92% keemstar only 9% now it's 90 back to
8% Dolly Lama yeah I mean yeah it's just
bad vibes who wants who wants to click
the button to vote even listening to it
is pretty icky yeah sorry Dolly Lama uh
but
uh all right we were we wish that uh
let's just keep them away from kids if
we can pleas thank you congrats key
dreamy
though okay up next we're coming to the
bottom of our right hand uh bracket here
there's three left up next is Jimmy Lee
everybody's absolute favorite on the
show those damn Crick uncontroversial
beloved by
all uh Jimmy the Jersey Outlaw here he
is with the drop of the year how about
him that was actually F tragic I'm sorry
to hear that yeah okay so so we're done
we're going to move past the straw roast
roast very good so let's do a set oh
wait a minute wait a minute I got I
forgot to tell you something what's that
you like my hat from Pink's Hot Dogs I
don't know if I mentioned it you didn't
no no you didn't yeah so I I uh I eat it
pinks when I got to La they got really
great hot dogs and um all different
flavors and it's a great place I mean
that's how Mr it's so good for
no damn reason all different
I will that is on my my hot keys that is
a a quick key sound but do you think
Pink's paid him for this no he just
loves Mr Pink he just paint it Forward
yeah I mean cuz he's like oh I forgot
and then he just goes into a fullon
unironic pitch for pinks I mean
they on the wall there
true true no we missed it Mr Pink asked
him to read it yeah it was Mr Pink asked
me to read it all right so all different
flavors also one more Jimmy one while
we're on the topic it's the stop with
tomatoes Dam my God stop with the
tomatoes you're killing me I just said
stop will you stop Jimmy we love you uh
and then that's verse Senator John
Kennedy reading
erotica
fantastic this is good stuff here
brothers and sisters and everybody let's
take
two books that have been much
discussed
um the first one is
called all boys aren't
blue and I will quote from
it I put some lube on and got him on his
knees and I began to slide into him from
behind I pulled out of him and kissed
him while he
masturbated he asked me to turn over
while he slipped a condom on
himself this was my ass and I was
struggling to imagine someone inside
me he got on top and slowly inserted
himself into me it was the worst pain I
think I have ever felt in my life
eventually I felt a mix of pleasure with
the pain this is really something this
is something else it is yeah go ahead Mr
Kennedy we're captive Captivate audence
all boys aren't
blue the second is
a what did you do you just read through
some like he's like I'm looking for the
hottest steamium he to read to my
friends in Congress he was really adding
some uh some inflection and some
embellishment on his reading there in
character yeah tell me more Mr Kennedy
another much disussed book book um I'm
sure you're familiar with it it's called
gender queer uhoh okay uhoh let me read
an excerpt from that
quote I got a new strap strap on harness
today I can't wait to put it on you hell
yeah it will fit my favorite dildo
perfectly you're going to look so hot I
can't wait to have your in my
mouth I'm going to give you the
of your life then I want you inside of
me end quote Jesus man that wow wow I
mean wow those uh other than tipster
those might be my favorite of the Year
those are incredible my favorite like I
can't wait to put my you're in my
mouth yeah it's so graphic and like dude
chill out bro you're in cogress have
some Decor what happened to the decor
brother and then he you this was my
ass so here it is we've got Senator John
Kennedy reading erotica versus Jimmy Lee
different flavors and tomatoes all
different flavors stop with the Tomato
look so hot I have to say um I'm
quite surprised by the outcome 67% Jimmy
pleasure with the pain I mean all
different flavors is a good one and you
all know I'm not the biggest Jimmy fan
but that's that's a banger sound B the
thing is too that there's been a lot of
push back on Jimmy since the docu
especially since the documentary Fiasco
yeah and I thought people might you know
R rally against him but I see that uh is
you're killing you got to separate the
art from the artist you
know the from the artist but anyway so
Jimmy congratulations this is big he I
think he's going to be really excited
about this I I'll give it 5 minutes till
he text me do we have him call in no no
kidding I'm kidding
kidding uh so there it is oh
oh dream nightmare nightmare or Dan put
your balls in my mouth oh that's such a
good one strong strong I use that so
much here's
dream what do you guys think of that
one I love it so what
is you guys want to learn it
[Music]
together we go goes I can't breath when
you're not there your Turn 3 2 1 I can't
bre you're not there you're not there
you supposed to learn a song that
nobody's ever heard before he because
this was uh he already performed the
song he performed the song and then
afterwards he did this little okay he
did it once but still like it's a new
song no how are they going to remember
the words they're not going to sing
along it's crazy right it's not that
complicated nobody's nobody dude Okay
let's listen nobody's singing along
sleep it's a nightmare he there's tons
of Parts look I can't sleep nightm crowd
sings about as good as Enrique night
this is a tough one it's
[Music]
a you're not there not my head num
heart he does the whole
chorus there you go not going remember
hook one more
time can we do
so go ahead and play our our winner now
to commemorate the meme because it was
really a good meme I feel that its life
cycle died
um he died it died young because of the
there was a new
dream uh controversy that I just didn't
want to have anything to do with but I
think it's time to bring it back because
the idea that we took his song that's
unpublished and now we made a song with
it that's our
song is phenomenal go ahead Zach I mean
your song
specifically Jersey law man and this was
the birth of the Jersey law man
really well not the birth but but I mean
this is his intro to the show this is
the first time right right you know he
had maybe come up once or twice before
but this was the first time he
participated in
contest is this is this the video that
has like 120,000
views it's like 200 and something now yo
that's crazy it's crazy dude and it's so
much better than his it gets recommended
to me on my main YouTube account all the
time and I click on it over and over and
over again because people they love it
yeah I think
dream I tried to hook him up with the
law man but he's just so shortsighted
man he doesn't see the
potential this is a hit
anyway you're not I listen to my
car it's good man it's so good I I I
love the law man what can I
say we all do so anyway that's
dream uh up against Dan put your balls
in my mouth but you got a lot of mileage
this year certain here it
is I'm Mr you Ste up to Mr gotcha I'm Mr
gotta
gotcha gotcha fall out of my mouth you
remember that commercial I Mr oh I
bucket a Mr Bucket Mr
Bucket put your ball in my head right is
nothing though put your balls in my
mouth Mr Bucket M balls fall out of my
mouth balls fall out of my mouth
it's so fun now did he say balls in my
mouth put your balls in my mouth he does
I think he says balls we ever find the
source for that the Mr Bucket commercial
I mean it's probably all over you I
really want to know what's the jingle
I'm Mr Bucket put your balls in my 1992
my mouth 1992 Mr
Bucket put your balls in my
mouth he might say that Dan let's see
1992 man I was seven years old that's
crazy I remember this oh wait hold
on I'm on the wrong output here is this
going to one second it says put your
balls in my top Mr Bucket out of my
mouth they will pop we're about to hear
well I don't want you to get claim Mr
Bucket yo who's coming for this 199 CLA
from 1992 and piss and be freak out
I appreciate that
[Music]
though
bucket Mr Bucket the first to get their
balls in Mr Bucket wins but look how cuz
the balls will pop out of his mouth I
think it was the the that was it you
just started talking right as he said it
the balls po out of my mouth the balls
come out of my mouth I heard put your
balls in my mouth I'm Mr Bucket your
balls pop out of my mouth which is fun
my mouth cuz I imagine a ball a testicle
coming out of the mouth would make a
like a put your balls in my
mouth Dan that's not what he said time
to get over
that anyway we got Dan put your balls in
my mouth uh courtesy of Mr Bucket thank
you Mr Bucket and against uh dream h
let's go the dream one is just I
love the whole story I love the whole
package of dream you
know then he called
in I really wish you would coake the
song man that was the ultimate but I
don't think we could do it now anyway
felt
yeah but it looks like Dan and apologies
to Mr
Bucket
the Oliver tree I
mean so yeah nightmare by dream is
taking the Dub here
62% well done so let's move on to the
final one here Mark Elliott uh the guy
who cured
Tourette's have a good night and a Nook
chestnuts oh brother brother
brother thank you for see this photo of
you guys of The Three
Amigos this
was that dude cim that was so
insane I was like oh I was trying
to keep a straight face I did
surprisingly Mark I think he was our
first victim right uh I think Sebastian
was first R yeah Sebastian was first I
don't know I don't remember I think so
yeah it was Mark I think the Nexium was
first yeah really poor guy dude I mean
poor guy well remember he he reached out
to us let me remind you he right we did
not initiate any of that he wrote us an
email asking to come on the show to talk
about Nexium so and I was like I love
that idea you know um so this whole
debate Arc was by pure chance it was by
thanks to Mark reaching out via email um
and asking to come on uhhuh anyway here
it
is did you I'm with you by the way aab
brother my voice you know that you don't
know how to turn off Zoom you're trying
but you can't get
away oh how do we how do you get out of
this no there's no TR well again nice to
meet you Ethan and uh yeah thanks for
having on I'm I'm sorry to put you all
through that It ultimately you are the
victim and I hope reneer dies in prison
I really do
I really do but one day you're going to
be free of this and I'll be there to
help you I'm so sorry you this is
Keith's fault that you went through this
it really is and I'm so
sorry yeah thanks thanks for having me
on today yeah thank you for joining us
all right take care have a good night
have a good night have a good night I
play that at the end of every Zoom call
we
have this interview was something man
brutal wow
oh wait somebody's commenting on this
already oh this is from nine months ago
oh this is my new favorite now
keemstar rimshot has been demoted to
number two this person is speaking this
is a soothsayer nine months ago this
person is speaking to the Future can I
give a quick shout out to this channel
each three podcast sound bites go ahead
they uh they post all the origins of the
sound bites It's amazing oh
that's awesome big shout out to them
thank you for doing that that's a really
cool project thank you appreciate that
um so that's Mark uh Elliot have a good
night versus a Nook chestnuts now we've
removed the music so that we can uh
enjoy his voice
unfettered yes go ahead anuki I did it
all for the
anuki then you have to use your
imagination that there's music playing
now
[Music]
CH so good feels so good
[Applause]
gorgeous theti cerella
thing happy to leave that in
2023 bringing chestnuts keep the Cutie
bring the chestnuts or no yeah the Cutie
keep the Cutie drama here Chestnut
chestnut's coming with us it was January
this year started off strong wow wow
yeah strong
[Music]
good
Legend I mean I could listen to this all
day but we do have a show to do on we
love you for that you actually let's
keep it going while the poll goes oh you
already did it
is taking it down
81% sorry
Mark have a good night I was hoping for
a dub for you after all the he God he
needs a dub he's still out there
fighting for Keith free Keith is he
really yeah
man he's a loyal Soldier I guess part of
me hoped that that would be the wake up
call for him he's in like deep deep deep
deep I guess so yeah sad well 76% says a
Nook only 24% for I am so sorry Mark I
really thought this might be a good year
for you but next year we're we're
looking up and our futures are bright
and I'm and I'm just I'm so glad that
the Tourette's is gone and that you're
doing
well all right that that concludes the
second uh half of yeah that's uh so we
are about to move
on and see some really powerful
matchups um let's let's take a look here
so just to run down the second uh half
of the bracket that we just got through
we had Michaela makeup bag win the first
round the second was taken by Rich Lux
uh talking about me
uh next up was uh Mayo from Sam Mayo for
Sam from Joe Biden Mayo for Sam followed
by xqc with his
ketta
uh next uh we have the keemstar rimshot
uh edging out the dolly Lama
followed by all different flavors from
Jimmy Lee all different flavors uh
dreams nightmare uh uh Acappella version
uh took that round and finally a Nooks
chestnuts of course so here's how we're
going to do the next
bracket we're just going to have Zach
play them so we're not going to do we're
not going to look back yeah now we can
start just blasting through them yeah so
um so let's go ahead and start at the
top here um can I step away for a minute
I got a pee go ahead all right of course
be right back I just I can't run the
stuff when I'm basement um so we're
matching up here we'll get it all lined
up uh it's I can't really see it's too
zoomed out but looks like we've got
cheers my dude versus eggshells cheers
my dude so play the whole thing the
tipster
one cheers my dude love you no homo
whenever we talk about burning the witch
you know the era where we used to burn
the witch that era never really stopped
the type of witch we was burning changed
and in order to comprehend you're going
to have to break
some comprehend in order to comprehend
and to eat the the the the omelet of
knowledge you're going to need to break
those eggshells he's so he really is so
eloquent and preach I like that his name
is preach because he really is preaching
to me to my soul made me defend this
dude can you set up the poll AB if
you're sitting yeah I'm over here got
dude so we got we got big tip it's up to
you I have whenever we talk about
burning the
witch cheers my dude wait someone said
where's Grim Shake that's
true so there's a lot of philosophical
thinking regarding this Rish Shake
wasn't really used as like a sound bite
a Nook and what was the other song One
dream both Zach uses those kind of more
in a sound bite do you agree with that
assessment Zach I do Grimace is more of
an intro and outro song okay more of a
song the other ones have more of a sound
by application okay correct that's fair
I'm glad that it was at least considered
and thought about yes would never forget
so right now we've got okay guys this is
close and I encourage everybody to get
their vot the winner of this bracket May
well be the winner of the whole
tournament cheers my dude is winning
with 5% the eggshells of knowledge
burning the witch 45% ab and preach fans
get your votes in cuz your vote matters
cheers my dude oh cheers my dude just
took another point lead I feel like I
say cheers my dude every day of my life
since since seeing that clip I'll be out
in public and uh you know podcast fans
will come up to me just cheers my dude
don't even say hi just cheers my dude it
is such a it really has
hour I I think it it's up there with a
baba
buoy so well okay so here's the thing
it's clearly the winner it keeps itching
up inching away cheers my dude at 57% we
can crown him the winner but I have to
say the eggshells one was is such a
phenomenal if it was up against anyone
else I feel that they would have gone so
far in this tournament I just love that
eggshell one so can you pay it for me
one more time order to comprehend you're
going to have
to comprehend in order to comprehend and
to eat the the the the omelet of
knowledge you're going to need to break
those eggshells yeah
man I like what but I can't deny it
cheers my dude I can't deny it cheers my
dude but I was rooting for f i don't
know yeah it was a tough one but okay we
have the winner cheers my dude advances
and this was kind of what we all
suspected might happening
that this might be cheers my dude's year
do you know how to move it up in the
bracket oh uh uh Dan is coming back so
Dan welcome back cheers my dude won the
first bracket oh already y okay
57% sorry Abba or
preach so up next we've got Gizzy
overdrive friend of the show we love and
Trump audio packet go ahead Zach
entering Gizzy over
overdrive really good and hit him with
just the
one just
oh all right so that's the Gizzy bot
Friends of the show we love him go ahead
with the Trump audio pack I did
everything right and they indicted me
Don't Call Him a fat pig Trump really
wow it's 104 or 5° in this room shut up
silly woman I'm trying to get their
attention turn up the
mic this one is
[Music]
amazing I'm
sorry Sor it's it sound it's like he's
having a fever dream and he's talking in
his something just something really
twisted anyway uh Trump is going to take
it Gizzy bbot we love you but I'll tell
you it was close 46% Gizzy bot 50 oh
wait it tightened a bit it's tightening
and the votes are still coming in it's
teetering here between 47 and
46 well Trump audio package has 54%
currently with 6,000 votes in it that is
pretty significant but we'll wait and
see but uh Gizzy bot we love you but
Trump really just had such a year for
sounds
yeah
so okay we're it's 57 Trump we're going
to call it Gizzy love you though buddy
yeah that's a trump though
congratulations Mr
President you know he might go to jail
he might lose all of his uh court cases
but at least he'll have won this
round consolation PR a beautiful
consolation all right up next looks like
we've got ooh the death bell
sound versus I never did and the
interview
boogy just take it in just take it in
remember everything that you
know we've experienced while this Bell
told and the how it resonates in your
soul just
two okay no we're ready we could do it I
was feeling it okay sorry but Boogie so
go ahead with the Boogie ones I never
did I never
did uh I did work at a small gaming
store back
in 2006 2007 I am disabled uh recognized
by the state of Arkansas but also the
United States government there's that
now the downside to that is I am
extremely depressed so there's some
mental health issues that we bring to
the table and then physically I I am
morbidly obese I have no references uh
no work history and no education and and
when you Google my name you might see
rumors that I beat my ex-wife and I am
also a pedophile should mention I'm also
a felon you can't beat that years I
never did you can't beat that you could
throw it up
but all right I'm throwing it up it's
just wow you know to be served such a
wonderful sound bite on like a
beautiful Sterling silver
tray just gorgeous what it's close oh my
God you guys this is this is surprising
me okay death bell sound 54% this is
really surprising the job interviews at
46% people please get your votes I never
did it it it matters I never
did I thought Boogie was going to sweep
this also a pedophile I love the I love
the death bell people love the love the
Bell man but that Boogie interview is
like legendary 52% death bell so it is
tightening 7,000 votes in guys please
cast your votes it's TI teetering oh
5149 it is so close I think what it
comes down to in my opinion it's a
versatility thing Bell can be played
anywhere Boogie it's got to be specific
yeah I don't know though I I feel like I
can make it work anytime you play it
it's
funny I mean I never did has some
versatility the job interview true yeah
and I do love that one 51% deathbell
people 10,000 votes oh 52 so deathbell
took a a stronger lead against Boogie
Wow real tight though real tight race
this really you know you never know here
on the sound bike Olympics folks you
just never
know uh that's 11,000 votes cast 52%
deathbell I think we can wrap it up and
wish Boogie a I mean it's well it went
from 51 to 52 so the trend is not even
going in the in Boogie's favor and
there's 12,000 votes in I mean uh but
you're right it's a lot I respect your
decision thanks Boogie I appreciate you
understand change your
mind you know I also was hoping Boogie
uh could take a win this year
but the deathbell uh
tolls for too powerful man everybody
yeah it's
coming Mitch we're coming for you
so congratulations to the death belt
yeah I guess we got to call it it's it's
holding strong here all right moving on
we've got Jesse Lee Peterson
mind-blowing sound drops versus loves
schuma loomas go ahead please
Zach wait wait that's not the matchup uh
it's it's uh it's sha Loompa versus uh
it's a rainy day in Los Angeles and you
screaming it's it two uh crew sound
bites against each other
oh interesting um so I'm gonna play low
first where's my Civil War where's my
shaa got it's that that sound is so
weird it's doesn't it sound like
a blown out weird
distorted it's a rainy day out here in
Los Angeles it sure
is listen I I personally don't
understand the hype on mine loves is
great where's my sha Loompa where is the
Shuma Loompa and also Taco Bell man
you know what have they done for us
lately have they reshot have they sent
us gift cards we've been riding for them
hard and I see nothing in they don't
with us dude they don't fck we've
sold more Taco Bell than that dog by now
for sure yeah RP by the way rip rip so
go ahead let's get the the uh voting up
we've got okay it's going up Ethan
package vers love shalas shut
up they sent us gift cards during Sam's
Chicken Sandwich taco that was a long
time
ago
right that was before my that's before I
even cha looking good 54%
55% very good yeah I think that's a dub
that's 56% you're pulling away yeah 57%
that's a dub wow that's a sha Loompa
Victory congratulations thank you sir
people get mad when you call it this
fast Ethan I'm just warning you there's
7,000 votes I'm
listen we have so much to do there is a
0% chance that mind overtakes it it is
my obligation
to% 8,000 votes statistically it would
be
impossible I maybe that's true where's
my sha Loa where is my shaa that's just
a blow up love does continue to uh pull
ahead though so I think I think you're
right that this is pretty much wrapped
up that's a sha loopa dub
congratulations love guys
congratulations
wow wow I appreciate that guys thank you
very
[Music]
much Hawk is proud watching proudly the
hawk didn't make it in to the bracket
this year I mean this year it was a very
Niche it's a very Niche sound effect but
was good though it did always make me
laugh honorable mention okay so um
fantastic well let's keep uh advancing
let's keep going Love's all the way up
to 60% by the way so yeah that was a
clear win I can't you got to move the
bracket cuz I can't see the uh
live oh and I I missed moving up the
death bell yeah wow guys oh I'm done so
that that's the first half here we have
tipster Trump death bell and Shuma looma
uh on this side let's go to the other
side all right moving on to this side
first up is Michaela versus Rich love
this is a really nice matchup yes this
is going to be tough I don't know what
I'm gonna choose so we got makeup bag
vers go ahead
yeah um is this going to make me look
like babby this filter is supposed to
make you look like
babby very good can't that's the one
that started at all oh yeah because Sam
play the one of Sam that's I saw Sam
doing it cardashian yeah like cardashian
weird and random why cardashian
yeah
so really a good impression
frankly uh up against Rich Lux
Dan Dan blocked me I can't stand
Dan I can't even ride Space Mountain
without Dan ruining my
vacation I can't stand
Dan sorry Rich sorry to hear that make a
bag
uh Lizzy Bell thank you so much in shout
out good luck out there at College we
love
you so all right I'm going to I'm going
to activate the poll here this is a big
moment guys please take this seriously
serious make sure your voice is heard
don't around it's up to you 50 okay
early polling is close Okay no it's not
oh wow okay oh my God this is a little
unexpected but I'm happy for God what a
blowout I thought Michaela had such a
strong year that is the Queen you can't
do nothing wrong Dan is the queen I
believe that the the Rivalry between
rich and Dan has is truly a tapestry of
fantastic
memories um we call that's that's a
clear rich I mean yeah that's a total
sweep
71% I apologize if people didn't get
their votes in but clearly the podium
here this one's pretty cut and dry
that's yeah and and apologies Michaela I
know you're you watch the show and I
love you and I'm so sorry that uh you
didn't make you didn't win so sorry so
sorry Dan and Rich have history there's
a lot of history there a lot of beef Dan
is jealous of me Dan the queen I'm very
very jealous all right so moving
on Mayo for Sam versus
K mail for Sam mail for
Sam
a carrot a
carrot a that anything wrong with
stre building constructive but just Pi
AR T across I can't believe he's
actually talking it sounds like he's
just
going like actually just doing that for
Sam all right we got mail for Sam thank
you Joe Biden we got XC
K this one could go either way I I
frankly have no idea videos oh oh
people are saying we forgot rectangular
did you all think consider that one we
we briefed about that yeah we briefed
about it it what it came down to is that
the well first of all we we for the most
part weren't including songs I know
dream nightmare came in there but it was
more the AC capella version than the
actual song that gets used as a sound
bite and then as far as the
rectangular uh Zach pointed out that the
one that the part of the rectangular
that's stuck in all of our head and that
gets the most use isn't actually Sean
Stevens It's The
Joker huh I'll play
it oh that
part but he does do a thing there though
he does he goes ah I don't know that
that's true I like the ah I hear the ah
but but I don't know he almost always
plays the Joker one yeah but I remember
that I'm rectangular ah ah so you guys
decide Ed rectangular does not belong
yeah well I mean it it was in the
running don't get me wrong but we had
you know we we had a bracket we had a
limited amount of slots and it just uh
it was using performance enhancing
sounds with the
joker it was Barry bonsing well I'll
tell you this they wasn't going to win
the whole tournament so ah very very
unlikely so okay well moving on we've
got let's see ker is winning
61% very strong showing on sorry
apologies to Sam and to President Biden
you know you guys had a really terrific
showing this year and and we're all
proud we
are but congratulations at xqc a car a
carot oh if he wins I'm going to
send him a uh one of those cool
calculator watches CIO yeah Casio I got
you
bro all right moving
down I can't see you got to move the
screen down for uh so next up it's a the
keemstar rim shot versus all different
flavors you know I got to pee again I've
been sipping down these Sodis but go
ahead with it and I'll be back I'm not
taking a pause to
pee so the keemstar rim
shot all different
flavors all different flavors may I say
these are both quick keys for me uh you
you have both of these on speed dial
correct yeah I mean they're both have a
lot of use get a lot of traction I mean
again uh I'm I'm Jimmy's number one
hater here but I I do love the all
different flavors and also it's not just
all different flavors uh we we lumped in
the stop with the tomatoes on this too
right you want to hit us with stop with
the
tomstar is also Brantly uh you are a
loser you're a loser you're a fun sucker
you are a loser you're my dad that was
this year are we certain about that that
feels so long ago yeah it was I CU I
remember I I watched it over winter
break and I'm like I'm saving this
before he deletes it and then we watched
it when I got back from break got it
yeah so it may have occurred last year
but it was introduced to the show at a
later time okay well I threw up the poll
and uh o we got a close one here Jimmy
is taking a pretty strong lead here
though 58 to 42
don't know if keemstar is going to be
able to overcome such a gap and in fact
Jimmy's lead is increasing as more votes
come in we're up to
59% uh I think I think it's pretty
obvious that Jimmy's going to take this
one I'll let it get up to 10,000 because
you know I respect democracy and I
respect your vote and I respect stop the
Tom yeah you know I want to give you
guys all a chance to make your opinion
heard here on the H3 podcast that's what
we're all about here on this podcast
is that your Terry Gross impression hi
it's Terry Gross thank you for listening
to NPR you'd like to we're doing our
winter fun drive right now if you enjoy
all of the programming that's brought to
you by MPR donate today and you can get
a year subscription to the New York
Times thank you so much for
listening now we're going to have uh our
next guest is going to be talking about
um cultural cooking from uh the
Caribbean yes and um and after that we
will be joined by a special guest who
will be talking about U Mongolian throat
singing here on NPR and if you enjoy
this kind of culture programming here on
the uh here on NPR then please consider
making a donation today to National
Public Radio all right we're at 10,000
votes Jimmy has got this locked
down he's at at
61% ending the poll right now Jimmy won
all different flavors all different
flavors stop with the
tomatoes uh nothing Jimmy won uh that
last round he beat out came Star by a
pretty healthy margin is 6139 guys know
what first of all I agree that that
sound bite is Iconic but you guys know
that you're inviting him back on the
shot we have to we can't ignore him if
he's going the distance wait what are
you talking about Jimmy
invite him back on the show yeah if he's
winning the tournament he got he needs
to make us he's not winning the
tournament I'll really yeah I'll rig the
no you won't I will literally rig
the no this the Integrity of this
is more important than any
thing I don't care about the general
election I don't care
about whatever's happening in Venezuela
is that what's happening yeah that's the
new hot spot that guy's crazy all right
round eight which is the final uh is
this semi-finals quarterfinals I don't
know has Jimmy texted you Zach
surprisingly no interesting he's
probably doing a root canal or let me
check my DMs some well if he did
you you would get a message I'd get a
text and cam would get a text he he hits
everybody yeah yeah let me
see all right um no nothing from Jimmy
thank God very
interesting all right uh so the final uh
of this round is dream night May versus
an Nook chestnuts wow two beautiful two
Titans beautiful songs would you like me
to play both songs is that just a bit
just give us a taste all right you got
it um one you can put up the poll and
while we're listening all right throwing
up the pole here we go one
second okay here we
go wait this is not the sound bite yeah
not that one his his oh I I I misunder I
thought you said song I thought you
meant that song no no no his voice is
beautiful he doesn't need background
music for it to be a
song sleep a
Nightmare Night nightm a nightmare I
[Music]
wow well okay dream is leading right now
54% an Nook I thought an Nook I did it
all for the anuki I thought he was going
to really have a big showing but 46% he
still got a chance 5,000 votes unok fans
get the votes in Rock the vote what do
they mean Rock the vote what does that
even
mean I think it was because it was it
started because it was like a rock
concert oh to get kids excited about
voting oh that makes sense but then
people still say it though
right uh or is that just I think it's
just kind of entered the cultural
lexicon now but it's an organization now
Rock vot as a nonprofit liberal
organization I got without that context
it makes no sense but we all we all just
walk on like it makes sense
right well damn enough I love you buddy
but you are getting you are not
advancing by the look of it dream 54% a
Nook chestnuts 46% 9,000 votes cast this
is looking like a done deal from my
vantage point yeah it looks like you got
it maybe there's a bit of a recency bias
going on on here cuz chestnuts has been
with us since the very beginning of the
year um whereas the nightmare thing is a
much more recent show meme so that might
be helping out a little bit Yeah you
it's so hard to say you know I'm see
some I I hate to say it but I see some
people saying they're over chestnuts in
the past a lot of people at the time
even during the the supremacy of
chestnuts people were saying I guess
it's always been a little controversal
it is it's highly highly contentious my
favorite is when Zach sometimes will
play a nuke singing uh My Heart Will Go
On just randomly I love good go ahead
Zach uh I have so many hold on I gotta
find it ah My Heart Will Go On where the
is it just play me any a Nook song
I love any a Nook hit us with some an
Nook but we can we can call it for dream
congrats
dude a Nook is a gracious loser and he's
decided to serenate you congratulate you
he is a gracious gracious uh loser and a
great
sport the sportsmanship is phenomenal
from
a all right thank you okay so with a
Nook moving up oops that's the wrong
layer uh here we go so we are closing in
you guys we're moving over back to the
left side so this would be the this
would be the quarterfinals that we're
entering right
now right that's that's correct yes it
would be the quarterfinals I mean
there's only there's eight there's eight
contestants left eight contestants left
four four rounds yeah so quarterfinals
tipster is going up against Donald Trump
wow it's about Dees of this room I think
tipster is going to win easy I mean May
Trump has been surprising us this whole
time sorry let's see they are strong
let's throw the pole up you guys know
what it is all right so quarter final
yeah throw it up Z you can play them as
as cheers Dude
Love cheers my dud my dude Trump package
yeah the the I did everything right and
they indicted me the Divide on chestnuts
is fascinating to me because I I just
love everything he does and people are
saying Fly Me to the Moon that was that
was really something oh that call a fat
pig fantastic one as well so we got
tipster vers Trump audio package now I'm
thinking tipster is going to win this
one and it looks like early pulling
shows shut up that it is in the lead
although it's quite close 54% tipster
47% Trump audio package this is very
close very close only 2,000 votes in so
let's get those big dumps in oh it's
narrowing uh and by the way I noticed
yeah I accidentally moved up a Nook
instead of dream I fixed it dream dream
was the one that that last round sorry I
tried to sneak him in there I was trying
to put weights in a
Nook 53% cheers my dude 6,000 it's
petering between 53 and 52 so it is very
close my dudes boy don't call him a fat
pig you can't do magga somebody post
this on the Donald so we can get some
Trump votes rest in peace rest in peace
um M turn up the
mic 8,000 votes it's too close I can't
call it until there's at least a 10,000
too close to Call's my dude
yeah currently at
52% dud love you 48% Trump audio package
this this is phenomenally close DED
[Music]
me it's about 110° in this room cheers
my dude love
you Mom they're both good
I'm
sorry I almost feel like these would be
my two picks for the finalists if if it
could have worked out that way
but this is tough cuz I love something
about the Trump one I love them all but
something about just voting for Trump
that just I'm adverse too you at least
I've seen what a vagina looks like true
what about you Trump have you well we
we're closing in on 11,000 votes and
it's looking quite stagnant it's holding
very St steady at that 52% Che dude so
that I think at this point at 11,000
votes and no movement in the past 5,000
votes we can wrap it up and call tipster
has defeated president Trump in the 2023
general
election we're going to have to do a
recount though cuz I heard that this
this uh election was stolen that's what
I
he Georgia massive fraud happening all
we need to find is uh about 1, 1300
votes you could just find me 1300 votes
even
less maybe 500 we just need 500
votes all right congrats tip big tip out
there man this is your year
buddy it's your year uh oh what's going
on Photoshop what are you
doing no get off of it it's like so as
you work on that the next one is we've
got the death Bell Nell ushering in the
Dark Age of Mitch McConnell the prophecy
says that when the full moon is ahead
and Mitch McConnell is
sacrificed that uh the age of demon will
uh cover the earth and the bell is heard
across the
lands versus chupal loopa wow go ahead
Zach where's my Shala where's my Shala
where is your Shala where's my shalpa I
think this what be might be where I die
where I lose you think so yeah I don't
think I got no
chance the Bell yeah the Bell got me the
Bell is is
stronga looma is a fan favorite clearly
the Bell is tolling oh my God what is
happening here where's my shaa where's
my sh can you throw the pull up or I can
do it yeah sorry can you throw this one
up cuz my Photoshop I got it baby oh
yeah I got it I got it do you have your
passports do you have your shots sha
looma
or
Belle where's my sh wow this is in WoW
I'll do
a all right people get your votes in oh
we got it we're get a live rendition in
in yes oh my God I love your work yeah
W come on here down now boy bring those
cha loomas on down here now
[Applause]
boy God dang chup
Loa I tell you they left my damn chupal
looma out there in California again God
Dam
it well love is trying to influence the
uh the voting clearly he's shaking it
he's dancing you know I'm just I'm just
enjoying myself over here well it's okay
I mean you should Lobby for yourself
shal looa it is close for considering
how incredible impact the Bell had on us
this year 57% Bell 43% sha
Loompa I think this is my time this the
Bell is ringing for you my friend the
Bell is ringing for the Sha Loompa I am
so sorry love but congratulations on
making it this far really oh no he's
gone it really is an exciting and a
special honor for you so yeah it is
thank you guys that very fun very nice
but it's it's quite close so that's
we're going to wrap it's a 10,000 votes
we can call it 55% Bell 45% shoala wow
we're narrowing in
guys that so we've got the left bracket
we got cheers my dude and death Bel
maybe we should wrap this bracket up if
you'd like to I guess it it doesn't
really matter let's let's prep for the
finals guys this is the semi finals the
winner ADV advances to the coveted final
match I guess so this a little confusing
we'll call the semifinal
one and it's uh tipster bracket one
semifinal baby cheers my dude cheers my
versus death bell
sound wow cheers my dude no homo oh man
this is a big moment this could decide
the fate of the tournament everybody's
on the edge of their seat somebody you
created the pole I've just hit send I'm
scared dude oh my
God guys get your votes in tipster and
the deathbell are in Fierce
comp 5050 bro 5050 what what th guys get
your votes in every vote matters 2,000
votes cast it is 5050 neck and neck
petering one up one down see matchups
this close these are two Titans of the
soundboard people get it in now tipster
is winning at this moment with
51% that is not sign that is not
statistically significant 5,000 votes
people now is the time to make your
voice heard now is the time to believe
democracy is real 50/50 again oh my god
oh
man oh God yeah you probably you
probably should have kept that to
yourself I guess man my guy my guy the
death bell is really showing such a
great it's such a great competitor this
year I didn't expect it to be honest
tipster pulled slightly ahead one more
time
51% closing in 10,000 votes 51% tipster
49% death bell sound oh my God guys we
need more votes we need more votes we
need more votes it's simply not enough
cheers my dude 11,000 votes it is still
5149 in favor of big big
tip wow Rock the Boat people rock it and
Dan this was your hope and dream and
your prediction is that tip would take
the whole thing down tip is my personal
pick for the winner but I don't want to
and listen I do not want to despar the
death bell that thing is a juicer it has
cracked me up so many times this year
Zach is a genius with it with his use of
it thank you very much it's it's a great
sound bite what can I say 50/50 is back
I I've stand with tip as well that's
my cheers thing is there's there's a
certain level of camaraderie because the
death bell is just it's just a bell it's
not it's not going to know it one right
and Mitch certainly wouldn't he doesn't
know what the going on well yeah
he's his mind is an alternat I I said
this for the start of the competition
cheers my dude is my favorite I'm I
voted for it well at this moment it is
13,500 votes cast this is too close
this is unbelievable please literally
out of my chest tipp's getting an
endorsement to three of the crew members
that's love you oh and I'll tell you
this thanks to YouTube's incredible
infrastructure we can't see the exact
amount that each one got so we need one
to go to 51 it does it does I believe
put the little highlight box 51 tip
around whichever one's in the lead so if
if it's 50/50 but one is ahead of the
other it'll have that box around
at this moment we have 14,000 votes and
this is for the finalist 51% let's go
Tipp in the polls my tip the in his
favor tip them 51% I'm coming out and
I'm endorsing tip
too late in the game for
that I'm not giving out my endorsement
but I understand I can't decide frankly
say vote I love the idea of tipster
winning I think you can't go against the
tipster Union cheers dude I'm not going
I'm just staining just fine 15,000 votes
that's a tremendous amount and I think
listen what a competition we're all so
blessed to be here on a day like this
people remember these for years to come
51% tipster cheers 49% death bell sound
chipster my dude you are advancing to
the
finals
wow okay okay cheers you love you no
homo
fck God damn
though intense intense hster made it he
made it all the he made it he made it at
least to the finals I don't know if he's
going to take it all but he is in the
last round is he weeding is he watching
do we have any no I don't think he has
any idea that we talk about who wants to
look at this fat face I can tell
him he know he knows we talk about him
no oh yeah I guess at this point he's
probably it's all love it's all love
it's all love all right moving on to the
uh right bracket the second bracket here
we need to name a champion of that
bracket so that we can name a grand
champion of the whole ass thing so who's
up first I can't see it because it's too
zoomed in uh okay it
is uh so right this would be our uh
quarter round quarterfinal round three
cuz we did a little out of order here uh
and it is Rich Lux Dan is the queen Dan
could do nothing wrong plus I can't
stand D plus all the other ones
against the king of twitch himself xqc
with
ketta all right let's get that pull up
and let's start listening to those
sounds understand Dan very good Dan is
the queen you can't do nothing wrong Dan
is the queen Dan is jealous of me love
that and Dan ruined my whole Disney
trip okay aot aot excuse see that's it
though just carrot no it's all the
mumbling and stuff too yeah I got
it I don't know Rich really rich I love
his sounds there Apple oh Apple too
right Apple yeah I got
it uh is the pull up it is right now all
right people this is an easy to me I
feel like it's an easy Rich Lux yeah
absolutely I don't know oh yeah it's a
it's a blowout Dan it's an absolute
blowout wow I guess xqc had an easy path
to the to the quarterfinals think he
must miy mous who did he compete against
uh well he defeated uh Mayo for Sam uh
which beat Kid Rock so technically it
beat all that out and then it also beat
out
Pearl uh wasn't there another oh that's
it huh no that's it all right well yeah
it didn't it didn't have too hard of a
path to uh to the porters here Lu 77%
and congratulation rich
rich easy you see K that's a huge that's
an easy win and we' love to see it good
good luck Rich we love you and we
appreciate you and Dan don't ruin his
Disney trip please I'll try I think
Disney I have never gone out of my way
to uh ruin anything for him but Dan ruin
I'd like to believe
that all right and then uh our final
quarterfinal
uh before we move on and find our last
finalist here all different flavors
versus dream
acapella the Jimmy Lee one is really
sneaking in here all different flavors
uh I really again I don't know which way
this is going to go all different
flavors I have no idea I can't SLE it's
a Nightmare Night nightmare a
nightmare can't you're not there you're
not there
let's
go all right I'm throwing it up
quarterfinal number four our final
quarterfinal the poll is up and We're
Off to the Races people I love I really
like the lore of the Jimmy Le it's just
it's just so random and it shouldn't be
funny for what he's saying isn't funny
but it is funny and that's so that's the
only time that Jimmy is funny but I'll
tell you Jimmy I'm so sorry to tell you
but early polling shows 53% in favor of
dream AC capella that is 47% so it is
very close but I will say their dream is
at an A Healthy Advantage at this moment
in a close race and in fact he just
gained another point 54% for dream with
6,000 votes cast my friends it's looking
like flocked up for dream how much is
this Pro dream and how much of this is
actually just anti- Jimmy I wonder I
don't know I think people really were
voting for Jimmy they really were yeah
you know I mean Jimmy beat out uh
Kennedy reading the erotica which was
very powerful exactly man so I guess you
might be right well with 8,000 votes
cast and oh it just it's actually
tighten a
little it just actually narrowed it went
from 55 to 54% dream 46% Jimmy Lee my
gosh but now it's back up to 50 we can
lock this up dream think so yeah 10,000
votes cast dream has 55% and Jimmy we
love you we're all rooting for you and I
look forward to all different flavors of
content from you and not just the same
one different we want different flavors
right dud I'm so tired me my eyes
are like
[Music]
closing all right I'm I'm calling it I'm
calling it I'm definitely going to need
something for the ride
home night congratulations dream this is
really something okay so we have a uh
semi-final round two to determine right
now
between oh and I forgot to move the
tipser up between uh Rich Lux and dream
here this is the semifinals of the
second bracket to Titans of the industry
Rich Lux down sound bite package versus
dream nightmare AC capella fantastic
years both strong strong competitors
let's see let's pull throw up the poll
and let's see who is going to advance to
the final stage
I can't stand there line wrong dad is
the queen I want to just uh compliment
and appreciate all the competitors thus
far it's been such a battle everyone has
put up just such a good fight such a
time of their life a phenomenal showing
by
everybody now
guys right out of the exit polling here
with 2,000 votes cast we have a clear
winner looking like Rich Lux is sweeping
this
yo I did not see this coming Rich Lux is
ahead 67% to dreams AC capella 33% 4,000
votes in this is truly stunning Ethan
Klein is like for the people thank you
bro I I love that one I don't think I've
heard I'm notar with that the stream to
me is rig right he was riding for you
okay dude this is on this is it I mean
there's 7,000 votes but there this is a
cold yeah this is a blowout Rich Lux 67%
to dreams AC capella 33% that's over I
can't stand Dan holy Rich Lux has
got to be stoked at home this is a huge
honor Dan ruin my whole Disney
trip all right well there it is so let's
just take a moment to reflect if you can
move him down there to the Winner's
bracket yeah wow here here it is tipster
vers Rich BL Che two
creators satellite uh friends of the
show I don't know that we've had that
before yeah interesting it was me and
Hanan last year oh it was wait you what
was yours fla did you win no I lost it
was Rigg wait who won that's not what
happened Hussein pcker no he didn't win
didn't he he came in second didn't he no
he didn't yeah you may have been in the
uh semi semi-finals yeah I think he
but then Han lost to uh what how right
hoe won yeah and let's be real it was
Ho's year yeah it was how's year it was
uh okay so we have tipster cheers my
dude and I got to say if it was anyone's
year it was Colin and she did not
perform right yeah now she got the boot
dude I think it's cuz the sound bites
are good they're not great though I
don't I don't care for them yeah yeah
well you're not alone nobody did but
golly what do we do what are of our
predictions here I mean tipster versus
Rich looks I didn't I didn't see Rich
looks going this far but now that he has
it's got me it's got my eyebrows raised
and I'm wondering is Rich Lux the dark
horse to win this whole tournament I
mean I I saw it coming I I feel like
I've been seeing comments throughout
pretty much the whole year saying Rich
Lux is going to win the sound bite
tournament at the end of the year and if
anything it's tipster is the kind of the
latecomer to this and uh even though it
it had a lot of fans here in the office
I I actually am surprised that it made
it all the way to the finals I uh that
one actually I I expected and I'll tell
you there's been a lot of lobbying in
this office for tipster which is fine
lobbying is Free Speech uh money is
speech I got to say though I think I
like the rich Lux ones just a little bit
more i' I've definitely said them more
randomly at stop lights just
random jealous of me uh real quick uh
Dan I got some bad news from you you
heard from Jimmy uhhuh Dan cannot stop
the Jersey Outlaw in a tomato what did
wait oh well you lost Jimmy yeah no you
lost but it wasn't Dan you're right Dan
cannot stop you you're an Unstoppable
Force nature my
friend are we uh well let's just get
should I show video should we I mean we
do do we just listen maybe just listen I
mean we've heard them all a million
let's Close Our Eyes let's really take
it in go play me tipster through and
through and let's just
Let It Ride feel it oh okay we're back
no that I pressed that as closing our
eyes oh oh bad
idea too high high level please uh
silence on the on the
court oh that's a loading screen Jesus
Christ did we're all silent go ahead
play cheers my dude love you no homo
Dan I can't stand
Dan Dan is the queen you can't do
nothing wrong Dan is the queen
Rich has a lot more entries and Dan
ruined my whole Disney trip right cheers
my dude love you no homo now Z I know
who you want to win yeah um but can you
at least appreciate Rich Lu being a
competitor absolutely I mean it's a
classic sound bite um great tone
uh
versatility you know Dan's always on the
show you know can always drop it right
the cheers my dude though
it's just like giving yourself a high
five it really is I and that's kind of
Zach's baby I think Zach was am I
mistaken Zach that you were really
pushing for that one like when it
initially came up like that was just out
of nowhere Zack played it well Ian
initially found it to give him credit
what's in the background there Ian which
was which one cheers the cheers might
did sorry my eyes were closed and
I no I just saw it I saw it floating
around you just saw it online somewhere
and thought it was so funny we We snuck
it in we had this idea because Ethan had
no idea about it and we started playing
it and he's like what the who the
is that and we're like don't worry
about it yeah CU we just started around
the office constantly cheersing each
other cheers my dude right it was some
inside uh yeah it was just like kind
started as an inside joke Che my dude
well it's not inside anymore he is a he
is in the grand champion running there
he is in the finals strong Aura to it
immediately woking guys at this moment
it is time to throw up the pole okay at
after a long year we sit here December
13th two shows left tipster and Rich Lux
both Friends of the show both family
cheers my
dude Nole is dropping now this is
intense I can't stand guys if your vote
matters at all it matters now get it in
people
do not let other people speak for
you Dan block me 2,000 votes in it
started dead even and then Rich just
took a commanding lead dude rich is at
62% now with 4,000 votes which is
frankly a commanding lead as Dan said I
was expecting a closer one but tipster
fans out there let's get out there and
start tipping because this is not
looking promising for cheers my dude
love no homo wow cheers my dude this
music's act so intense 7,000 votes cast
62% Rich Lux I am not seeing any motion
what this continues to be a blowout a
shut out for Rich Lux the tipster team
is mourning they cannot believe what's
happening now they're in the they're
they're just stunned they're saddened
39% they did score a point tipster
scored one point there it's 39 to 61
okay okay but it's too little too late
probably on the field
here and you know I got to give my heart
goes out to the tipster fans because
they thought this was this their year
they was wearing their hearts on their
sleeves they invested so much into this
and uh I really my heart goes out to
them but I have to say Rich Lux team
rich is ecstatic this is a huge moment
for Rich
Lux
Queen guys I think we we can call it
because 12,000 Lux Rich Lux is holding
firm at
61% Rich Lux you are the winner of our
fourth annual sound bik tournament
wow it
up wow
wow what I am I am so happy for you man
I am so happy for you buddy I I got to
be I did not expect this I really didn't
see I I
I I just had a feeling it was going to
go all the way I was pulling for tip you
know I made that clear that I was
cheering for him but I respect those
Rich sound so much though huh you wanted
rich I wanted Rich yeah you did why you
say that because you guys have there's a
k
[Music]
it's a other yeah sure yeah and true
Zach how are you doing are you doing
okay I'm doing good I'm glad tipster was
in the finals but rich I tip the crown
to you my friend well done tip the crown
tip the crown to you and
Rich you're the champion and Dan is no
longer the queen Rich you're the queen
there it is is so right
Zach I got to say
um this is our fourth annual and what a
tradition we've built here we really
need to build a Pantheon to honor all of
our winners we need to plan something
like that yeah that's a good idea now
that like it's really become a tradition
I I think having kind of like a hall of
fame or something would be pretty cool
absolutely yeah so um well guys it's
been fun it's been another fantastic
Sound by tournament and it's fun every
time I had no idea this was going to
happen I didn't I really
didn't um so we will be back on Friday
for our final in studio show uhhuh and
Sunday at 700 p.m. I hope you will all
tune in it's available for everybody
live on our Channel our live show we are
doing the steamies live it is going to
be so much fun it's you SE we've been
working so so hard on this and and uh I
hope that you all come and join us and
enjoy the
show really going to be a terrific show
I
think at the historic Dolby theater in
the Dolby Theater the very same Dolby
Theater where the Academy Awards the
Oscars that you all know and love suck
it streamy you could only dream of doing
it there same stream to me streamy like
we're holding it this year at the
conference Hall at the holiday in yeah
right nobody cares that's where you know
no offense but that's where like they
have like
a quake con what was it sure yeah Quake
conon would be that's the type of thing
that would happen in a holiday in
no offense to the Quake fans out there
we love
them but um thank you guys thanks for
participating really wow what a magical
show it really is just such a special
time of the year it's a good one yeah
think K is like for the people thanks
brother I know that's true and I
appreciate you saying that I can't stand
Dan love that lots of uh thanks to Zach
rolling in in the chat by the way I'm
seeing a lot of props cuz he is the real
queen all these sound bites they
wouldn't be anything without Zach true
very true thank you I really appreciate
that thank you thank you Zach this is
truly a dedication
to and he didn't win but tipster I
love you man cheers my dude
cheers my dude cheers my dude love
you love you at least I know what a
vagina looks
like well we'll see you on Friday guys
um and I hope you all have a fantastic
evening and a great healthy safe
Thursday and uh well I'll see you then
maybe the doggy will be here on Friday
if can say love ducky little ducky yeah
you guys are going to love ELO told me
he pooped outside he peed outside
twice really
good all right y'all thanks for watching
love you guys sincerely and thank you to
the members by the way you guys make it
all happen here and I'm so grateful for
that and everybody who watches it's an
honor to have you so thank you everybody
and we'll see you on Friday
[Music]
Dan I can't stand Dan Dan is the queen
you can't do nothing wrong Dan is the
[Music]
queen